seats
foreign
thank you
[Music]
the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who was
the house adjourned from the session of
March 22nd 2023. are you ready for the
question all those opposed all those in
favor say aye president Paul's name the
eyes have it the house is adjourned they
also attend to a Prayer by house
chaplain Reverend Bob Stewart pastor of
Saint Paul's United Methodist Church in
Manchester
good morning Mr Speaker good morning
House of Representatives
let us be in a spirit of Prayer
good morning God
we thank you o God for this day and it
is in the rising of the Sun that we see
you and the beauty of the world your
hand has created
we see the purple mountain majesties
above the fruited plains
New Hampshire
New Hampshire God shed his grace on us
and crowns his good with Brotherhood and
Sisterhood
from sea to shining sea
Oh beautiful for spacious skies oh God
you have created
help us to pause and appreciate
what you have created
God you are the source of all life
creating and sustaining every living
thing
you are the source of all food that
nourishes Us in both Body and Soul
nourish us this day as we work together
for the common good
for the State of New Hampshire
you are the light that dispels the
clouds of error and doubt
and you prepare the way for us every
hour of each and every day
and we pray that you will guide our
thoughts and our actions as we engage in
all the business that will come before
us this day
I pray that you keep your guiding hand
upon each member of this house
I pray each of us feel your presence in
all we do and say
and I pray for all the leaders of this
house
give them the wisdom
so they can lead with integrity
and with authority
a loving God may we be like the son
rise to the challenges presented today
and give us the ability to fulfill
our appointed duties of this day with a
readied mind
and an act of spirit
in your name oh God we pray
amen
do you recognize the member from Wilton
representative Jim Cole fault will lead
us in the Pledge of Allegiance
chair recognizes the Wilton blind
Borough Cooperative Middle High School
select choir who will now sing our
national national anthem
[Music]
of say can you see
by the dawn's early light what's so
proudly we have
help at the
twilight's last gleaming
Bright Stars
[Music]
foreign
for the land of the free
and the Heart of the grace
[Applause]
foreign
Mr Speaker the day Representatives
baruti hatch McCarter Nelson and stavis
the day important business
Representatives Ankerberg near
inverville the day illness in the family
representative shamberg and trottier
these leaves shall be granted unless
otherwise ordered by the house
I also attend to introduction of guests
Mr Speaker please walk please welcome
Mary macris and Maureen white guests of
Representative Freitas Naomi long guest
of Representative naughter
partner of Representative Tim Horgan
Taryn Anderson and Katie Gosselin music
director and assistant principal of the
singers guests of Representative kovalt
Joseph ribsim Cassandra Sanchez Susan
Stearns Rich Gula Michelle wangarin Mark
beaudwin and Karen Rosenberg guests of
Representative Edwards they are with us
in the gallery today
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
we also have a very special guest
in the gallery today
we want to welcome in specialist Brendan
Tuttle and his family
specialist Tuttle
is with the crew member in Brave battery
Third Battalion 197 filled artillery
Regiment of the New Hampshire Army
National Guard
he has been awarded soldier of the Year
following the New Hampshire Army
National Guard competition last month
the House of Representatives was like to
present you with a declaration to
recognize this achievement
congratulations to specialist Tuttle for
earning soldier of the year and on
behalf of the representatives in the
state of New Hampshire we'd like to
thank you and the men and women the
197th field artillery regiment for your
service
and I learned this morning that
specialist Tuttle is being deployed to
Kuwait
welcome specialist title
Godspeed specialist Tuttle and come home
safe
Mr Speaker
for what reason memorize thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I'd move the jury
marks be placed in the permanent Journal
without objection
the house will now continue with the
regular calendar House Bill 49 that was
special ordered for today
foreign
we have Edwards
the house will be in order
committee on finance to which was
referred House Bill 49 FNA act relative
postponing the closure of the sununa use
Services Center could citizen report the
same with the following amendment that
the recommendation that this bill ought
to pass with amendment of Senator Keith
Earth for the committee
the committee amendment is zero eight
nine two H printed in house record 16
pages
51-55. are you ready for the question on
the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted
representative
representative Edwards offers floor
Amendment
1104 H it's in your seat pockets
okay
congratulations
I never picked up
[Music]
um
thank you
exclamation point
I recognize representative Edwards uh
thank you thank you Mr Speaker
I Rise to um to make the motion that we
reconsider the amendment that just
passed I I think uh there were people
that wanted to speak on it that ought to
be heard
commotion before us to reconsider
the vote on the amendment
on House Bill 49. are you ready for the
question
all those in favor reconsideration say
aye those opposed nay the eyes have it
and reconsideration is adopted
we're back to the
original committee Amendment
which is zero eight nine two h
and the chair recognizes representative
Stringham
good morning everybody and thank you Mr
Speaker
the opening Clause of the Law related to
juvenile offenses States if the court
finds that a minor is delinquent the
court shall order the least restrictive
of the following dispositions which the
court finds is the most appropriate to
emphasize the court shall order the
least restrictive which is most
appropriate
there are two types of incarceration
impacted by this bill the first is
commitment
commitment is what occurs after the
adjudicatory hearing or trial at which
the miners found guilty or after a plea
agreement
the second type of incarceration is
detention
detention is analogous to an adult being
held without bail after arrest one of
the goals of this amendment was to
reduce the number of children being held
without bail for offenses that typically
would not result in an adult being held
without bail as concur occur under the
existing law one aspect of this bill is
the Limitless offenses for which a child
may be held without bail in the absence
of extenuating circumstances to Serious
violent offenses
holding children in jail is not the best
way to help them towards a better path
New Hampshire has spent tens of millions
of dollars now into the hundreds of
millions of dollars over the past four
years on a system of care for children
we lead the nation in developing these
wrap-around service that provides a
child and their family with 24 hour a
day seven day a week real-time support
that support ideally comes at the
child's home setting but as that becomes
unworkable New Hampshire has built a
network of residential facilities
dealing with the increasing level of
support
so the committee Amendment focuses on
keeping these children accused of
low-level offenses in these types of
facilities these provide a better
environment in the trauma
in trauma-informed care to help the
children at the same time they provide a
less costly alternative to the state
which is another goal of the amendment
we have heard about in the about in
committee about the building during this
process how we must rush to get this
bill to complete construction we
appropriated funding to secure a
forensic Hospital four years ago with
the same urgent need we still haven't
broken ground on the construction of
that facility today the reality is the
current environment it will take time to
build a replacement in the meantime
we'll focus on the culture of the
facility where the children will be held
part of this amendment puts forth
guidelines that the director of the
facility will have a background in
Psychology nursing social work or
medicine and experience in
trauma-informed care in congregate
settings with juveniles
but in light of the fact that the
current operating costs in the facility
can exceed one million dollars per child
year
the guidelines are included to provide
that the new facility be designed with
operating costs in mind and that these
costs be reviewed at least biannually
Banning allele thank you the committee
Amendment includes a definition of
trauma-informed care to further guide
the understanding of the desired
cultural change
trauma-informed care means a program
organization or system that realizes the
widespread impact of trauma and
understands potential paths for Recovery
recognizes the signs and simple symptoms
of trauma in clients family staff and
other individuals involved with the
system and responds
by fully integrating knowledge about
trauma into policies procedures and
practices
our committee Amendment provides for
additional information in the quarterly
report provided to the legislature
specifically it requires that the
reporting of the highest level of
charges for commitment or detention
excluding any personal information this
is not currently available making it
difficult to analyze what is bringing
children into the facility and the
breakdown of those being detained or
held without bail and those being
committed who have been found guilty of
an offense this information
included in this amendment
uh is continuing to improve the outcomes
of the facility
the committee Amendment received a
strong bipartisan 23 to 2 recommendation
so please join me in supporting this
bipartisan committee amendment by
pushing the green button thank you Mr
Speaker
I recognize represent a Marjorie Smith
okay
you should you should speak now and
representative Smith will speak after
chair recognize representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr Speaker I I wasn't
prepared to do this I had been led to
believe that there wasn't going to be
any opposition to the floor Amendment
because of the extremely strong support
of the advocacy community and so I I
understood that we had all agreed to
agree and speaking of agreeing to
agreeing
everything that you just heard from the
well is the exact same thing as as what
is in the uh alternative amendment that
you'll see in a bit but there are a
couple of exceptions for it
the word was used that there are
representative Edwards yes your Fuller
Amendment isn't up yet so no I know I'm
now I'm speaking to the remarks of the
previous speaker
so so like I said the the goal stated by
the previous speaker the words in the
Preamble about uh
trying to find the path to the least
restrictive care for the uh the the
juvenile involved in the system all of
that is the same There's no distinction
the term Limitless reasons why somebody
could be
placed in the facility is just false
it's not Limitless they're they're
specified they're enumerated they've
been reviewed by the judicial system
there's a worksheet on it where you have
to tick off specific things it's
extremely well-bounded extremely well
disciplined it is not at all Limitless
and and I propose that we should not be
changing that on the Fly what do I mean
by on the Fly
the most onerous most objectionable
aspects of this current finance
committee amendment is that it was all
done in a non-germaine amendment in a
crisis time when Finance is supposed to
be focusing on closing in on the budget
and although children and family law had
HB 120 and although the members of
division three had been invited in
January to sit in with the children and
family law back in January
this these proposals to change the
Public Safety Code and to add some
budgetary restrictions these all came
in the last week where Finance is
supposed to be focusing on a 13 billion
dollar two-year budget this was not the
time to bring it to finance nor was it
the correct committee to to bring it to
the committee of jurisdiction in this
case is children and family law and we
had the chairman of Children and Family
Law come to us during that non-germaine
Amendment hearing and specifically ask
us to not pass those
um restrictions those Provisions to let
them with as the committee of
jurisdiction review them so so why is
there a need to move forward with this
we have to build a facility to build a
facility we need money we are attempting
to lock in the federal money so it
minimizes the state general funds
expenditure every time we delay this and
has been delayed successfully way too
many times every time we delay this we
put at risk the the use of the federal
funds so we got to stop the delay and we
got to move forward if the if this
finance bill gets to the Senate it's
going to be rejected excuse me the other
body it's going to just be rejected and
we're going to end up going into another
Committee of conference or maybe a
committee of chaos we should not do what
we know will fail
and it's not just me saying that the
finance Amendment will fail we have The
Advocates of the community that that are
here you know guests today on behalf of
this bill include Joseph ribson of dcyf
Cassandra Sanchez the child advocate
Susan Stearns of Nami New Hampshire
Karen Rosenberg of the disability rights
Center of New Hampshire Rich Gula of the
state employee Association Keith Koenig
from the New Hampshire legal assistance
Community or I don't know if that's
right
anyways Keith is here and Mark buden of
the New Hampshire Police Association you
also got a letter with a tremendous
number of signatories saying please
don't do the finance Amendment don't do
this so if you will vote in opposition
of the finance Amendment then we can
introduce a another amendment that has
tremendous Broad and deep support by our
citizens thank you
I recognize representative Marjorie
Smith
Mr speaker thank you as always for your
courtesy and agreeing to change how this
debate would proceed and I would like to
welcome the people who are in in the
gallery who over the years I have worked
with very closely on so many issues
where we share the same concerns
I rise today in support
of the amendment to House Bill 49 that
passed the committee with a 23 to 2 vote
15 years ago I was privileged to serve a
chair of house finance and was
introduced to the synonym Youth
Development Center
what I learned has been on my conscience
ever since
if we were to be judged by how we treat
our children
indeed our children most in need of help
we would be found wanting
the juvenile system was created more
than a hundred years ago as research
demonstrated that children are not
miniature adults
and in each succeeding decade we have
learned more about how human brains
develop
putting young people who have not
behaved according to acceptable
Community standards in prison is
guaranteeing
that it will be almost impossible for
them to function successfully in society
but that is what we have done and are
still doing at the sununa center
I will not address in any detail today
the appalling Behavior by some dcyf
employees that has come to light
but I will address the culture the
culture of the institution young people
were kept in isolation violating the
most Elementary understanding we have of
human growth and development they were
kept in restraints
violating our own state law when a
federal agency confronted them they
replied that they were working on how to
comply with state law not at all
concerned that they were in violation
just this week
three days ago the individual
responsible for the agency confirmed
that children at sysc are strip searched
they are strip searched every time they
leave and return to the facility going
to court
to medical appointment or a family visit
can you imagine how that traumatizes
already vulnerable young people
the committee amendment that passed 23-2
was supported by
two former Finance chairs one Republican
and one Democrat
a former Republican chair
of children and family a former chair of
Finance who is still serving on finance
and in fact the current chair of Finance
what this amendment addresses and what
opponents seem to focus on is language
addressing over Staffing concerns and
per bed cost after all it is the finance
committee and when they say it's not the
money you know it's the money
both of these sections are advisory and
do not set a specific budget they are
attempting to deal with the bloated
budget of sysc over the past decade that
dcyf has shown no ability to reasonably
control
those of us who support this amendment
believe that fewer children should be
committed or detained and instead should
be cared for in their own communities
this not only affects the budget but it
keeps many low-level offenders from
incarceration
we know that incarceration is a
traumatic experience for anyone but
especially for vulnerable children
opponents focus on why children should
be incarcerated we're focusing on why
children charge with low-level offenses
should be treated in the children's
system of care a system focused on
community-based treatment that we have
appropriated tens of millions of dollars
to implement
yet we continue to over incarcerate
children charged with low-level offenses
while legislative pressure has resulted
in a dramatic decline in the number of
children currently incarcerated we have
failed miserably in changing the culture
our Amendment and the finance passed
Bill takes several steps to assure that
trauma-informed care is the focus of
the new facility and the current care
for these children we address cultural
concerns within the facility by
prescribing direct or qualifications we
would require that the direct director
be not a corrections officer a warden
but a trained professional in dealing
with children with very special needs we
do not assume that we know all the
answers we ask in fact for additional
data to assess the effectiveness of
these interventions
we provide a clear definition of
trauma-informed care we require sysc to
practice
trauma-informed care and we require that
staff should be trained and trained now
in trauma-informed care you don't need a
new building to start that
when we decided to build sysc 20 years
ago
the department told us that this would
fix the issues at YDC its predecessor
the Youth Development Center such as
overcrowding and allegations of abuse 20
years later the sununu center has the
same problems the same problems as YDC
and now the director tells us I know
better this new facility will fix the
issues
you likely have heard and perhaps even
read that there actually and you've
heard from the sponsor that there is
um another amendment
there is nothing in that amendment that
assures that the new facility will be
anything other than a a miniature sysc
there is nothing that says that we won't
be doing the same things we've been
doing for years and failing
the same thing that caused more than a
thousand children to allege physical and
sexual abuse the state has been made
liable for hundreds of millions of
dollars as if money could heal wounded
bodies and Minds
and the fact that nearly two-thirds of
the Children released from the sununu
center return
as recidivists indicating the inadequacy
of the treatment they received this
should not be baseball's Field of Dreams
if we build it they will come if you
think that thousands of children
alleging abuse indicates that we need to
take a different approach to the
treatment of juveniles then you should
vote for House Bill 49 as passed with
the committee amendment 23-2 by the
finance committee and reject any
additional amendments as the committee
did by an equally strong vote thank you
for your attention Mr Speaker
the house will be in order
the motion before us is the ought to
pass motion on
committee amen adopting committee
Amendment zero eight nine two h
well remember yield the questions
no Mr chair I missed it
the member does not yield
we've had a question a request for a
division vote members to take your seats
you're doing the pi yes
yes we're doing the pi yes what's that
they're doing the pi against it
yes we already have
I need to know
is
all right
the house will be in order
the motion before us is adoption of
committee Amendment
0892h this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative Edwards
for a parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you Mr Speaker uh I Rise to
explain uh that if if I knew
if I knew that uh today was the first
time
any representative has publicly said
that they don't want any new facility to
be built
that's shocking and if I knew that the
finance amendment was rushed and the
issues in it went to the wrong committee
and if I knew that this bill will be
rejected by the other body
leading to a committee of Chaos
this is how it failed last time we got
hung up in a committee of chaos and if I
knew division three has directed the
equipment to replace the strip search
upon the very first term we even heard
that was an issue we immediately
approved 300 000 to go get the equipment
because we care about this this is a
parliamentary yeah and if I knew that
many Finance people in finance voted for
I'll call it the Lynn Amendment which is
before you because it was less bad than
the first alternative and that the
amendment sponsor opposes it now is do I
I voted for it to
preserve some flexibility and and then
if I knew that I agree that the past
decade has been a failure representative
this is a problem this is the last one
if if I'm
if I knew that the past decade has been
a failure in coming up with a new
concept would I and that this is going
to be a new trauma-informed therapeutic
center would I now vote and press red in
order to kill the amendment so that
another could be provided
do you recognize representative hole for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that children's lives matter
and sometimes children make bad choices
by accident not premeditated choices but
accidental choices
without understanding the consequences
of those choices
if I agree with The Advocates who want
to change the Paradigm to
trauma-informed care so children who are
growing up and developing have a better
shot at Living outside of the Criminal
Justice System
if I know that today we spend between
800 and 800 000 in a million dollars per
child for incarceration
and that the amendment tries to drive
that to the more normal cost of four
hundred thousand dollars
if I know that we discuss Staffing
ratios at four staff members per child
not some of the hyperbole I've heard
if I know that The Advocates were asking
for at least one to three and we were 12
times that amount because children's
lives matter
and if I know that this could have
started years ago in the same facility
all the changes that we're asking for
require some of the statutory
construction
if I know I will represent the
representative this is a parliamentary
inquiry thank you last one
if I know
that this is the right thing to do and
the committee adopted this 23-2 what I
now support HB the amendment to HB
49090892 and press the green button
thank you
we're in the voting we're in the voting
mode right now this is a division vote
and everybody make sure your voting
stations are on
the motion before us is the committee
Amendment
0892h this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
press the green button of your opposed
you'll press a red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
thank you
okay
the house will be in order
represent malwiki
representative Schultz sorry I missed
you
are there
all right
members president had an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
200 voting a 179 voting a committee
amendment is adopted bills on second
reading open to further Amendment
representative Edwards offers floor
Amendment 1104 H it's in your seat
pockets
representative first oh all right chair
recognizes representative Potenza
he's recognized
thank you Mr Speaker
honorable General Court I rise today in
strong opposition to the amendment of HB
491004 for several reasons
for one I was born and raised in the
Live Free or Die state in Match Vegas as
we called it
um
and I know all about what YDC was I had
a very good friend that went to YDC Paul
and uh was actually one of the the cases
the stain on this state is unbearable
and this is this amendment is actually
not the way to go I believe that we have
to support exactly what the committee
adopted I don't care what deals were
brokered the main change of this is
about the money
and this going over to in a sense
the governor and the executive Council
and the joint legislative fiscal
committee and that's really where this
comes to is we as the general court are
first and foremost all money bills
should be coming through US ten thousand
dollars anything above that is coming
through us we are not
we not by six people which means the
governor in the executive Council which
have been rubber stamping millions of
dollars under our noses our constitution
clearly states The Entity of the general
court our our basically our Authority is
us not a portion or a committee or
subsidiary we have already seen these
land grabs happen very recently in the
last two years of the last budget for
example for any Representatives that are
from belknack County and they know what
took place and what got pushed into the
budget last which was the Laconia land
grab everyone knows that correctly how
about the folks that are here the
representative I would extend that you
keep your remarks to the amendment
okay so this is about the amendment
because this is basically giving the
governing the executive Council carte
blanche of 150 acres of prime real
estate that's what's going to happen
right now the department of
administrative services will take care
of the sale of the property I believe
this property should be
should be utilized to represent all of
the children that were abused more than
a thousand that have come through
um at this point build a beautiful Park
have a water park have a memorial for
these this is there this should be their
money not our money we shouldn't be
making money on this because of what of
other abuses that took place for all of
those years in 1855 the sole purposes of
that property was for the Reformation of
juveniles it was selected because it was
a hundred plus acres of prime Farmland
if you are from new Manchester you know
that is the North End of Manchester it
is Prime real estate it's in a beautiful
part of the city
um
my last thing I want to say is that it
took place in Concord for the same exact
thing that happened two years ago
um it was actually you know where the
old Administrative Building is it's on
uh Stickney Street
um the governor actually sold that to
his Brady Sullivan folks and it was
supposed to be to the city of Concord
this this has nothing to do with the
amendment so one million dollars that
was sold for when it actually is a
multi-million dollar property that's
what's going to happen representative it
has nothing to do with the amendment
does it does okay so please
um kill this amendment thank you
chair recognize representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr Speaker and I want to
thank everyone who supported the special
order today so that we could offer have
our guests in the gallery guests who are
credible and committed to taking care of
these kids and looking at the
alternative that they've helped craft
over the last two years
um I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you four
things I'm going to tell you what this
is really about how we got here the
distinct distinctions between the
amendment they just got voted on in this
amendment and and I'm going to ask for
your vote I won't read the names of the
gallery guests again I think you all
remember that I just want to say that
they are an honorable and Noble group of
people of dedicated professionals who
support this amendment they've
communicated with you directly to let
you know that they support this
amendment and I'm proud to sponsor this
in a non-partisan way on a policy basis
with the chairman and vice chairman of
Children and Family Law and also an
important member of Children and Family
Law who also serves on the oversight
Commission of children's services these
Representatives come from Hampstead
Exeter Wyndham and Manchester also the
chairman of the Judiciary is on as a
co-sponsor here you received the letter
what was this about
well in the very beginning of the sununu
center it was built for 144 kids and it
was built built mostly to be a jail
in the last decade the legislature has
been complaining about the sununu center
and no effective action was taken I
thought we had this taken care of two
years ago until an agreement that was uh
was put into place uh it got killed in
the committee conference
two bills had passed both sides of the
house there was a path to reconciling
them but the reconciliation was rejected
at the last minute on a broken promise
we then formed a joint committee to look
at the replacement
out of that came sb1 and hb120 you know
sb1 we did a slim down amendment of it a
few months ago there was also H20 which
HB 2120 which was a parallel bill that
children and family law heard with
division three present and they've
chosen to retain it to help you know
address any stray issues that that may
come out of this effort
initially the sununu center was a jail
everyone has agreed that we need a rep
to replace it with the trauma-informed
therapeutic care model we've all agreed
to that so so please don't listen to the
distractions because we've all agreed to
that that's why the community is on
board as a matter of fact so what what
did we do this bill focuses on the
change concept going from a jail to a
health care setting that's secured okay
so as a health care professional planner
I know this is a health care setting of
course the facility is a key part of it
today is the first time anyone stepped
forward and say they don't want a
facility it's kind of late in the
process there's also Workforce issues in
here on on the kinds of clinical care
that should be available there's also
service sharing that's in here so that
we can be smart about the resources that
go into it for future operations and
then the funding that I mentioned we
made sure that all the money that we
could came out of the federal money if
we delay this we're putting that Federal
money at risk
so 120 hb120 Was Heard and retained by
children in family law
and that's ready for further study the
leadership of Children and Family Law
are all on board that they're going to
listen to any new ideas and consider it
and bring legislation forward uh in in
January should there be a need
the amendment that is with you
got a 12 to 13 vote in finance and one
of the members happened to be a
republican I think would change their
vote if they had a chance to do it again
so had we been able to get this 13 to 12
we might not be here today
what
has happened is that the bills and I'm
so sorry to talk so long you know I
really am because I just did not
anticipate any of the prior debate I but
but so anyways the things that you must
know to make this vote because this is
about the future
is that
there are three components to what is
floating around part A is the part of
sb1 that we agreed to with the Senate
with the other body
uh you know Part B is this amendment and
part C are the new things that got
introduced in a non-germaine Amendment
at the last minute when Finance was
focusing on trying to get a a budget put
together
we were asked to not do that and to send
it over to the children and family law
but for some reason we rejected that
very clear request
so part A eliminated the closure date
that was going to be one March so that
was really critical gave four months of
funding it established the site
selection process and the obligations it
funded the site selection and it allowed
for two different capacities a small and
a medium
this four amendment is Part B what does
it add it adds clinical and safety
guidelines this is a health care setting
that's secure
it agrees that we've all agreed that it
should be operational for 12 with a
maximum capacity physical capacity of
18. so finally the capacity thing that
killed the committee of chaos last time
has been resolved so that's progress
it funds us with Federal money first it
funds the design and construction
because in the previous Bill there was
no design and construction money just
site selection money this directs that
the site be co-located with shared
services to get our operational costs
down
um so what's the problem with with what
Finance passed like I said many times
it's a non-germaine Amendment In the
Heat of the budget battle there were two
hours of debate followed by an immediate
executive session as all of you know
that is not good legislative process
okay that is not the way to do it we
were asked by the community don't do
this send these new things over to
children and family law children and
family law are prepared to deal with it
um so it added dramatic changes to the
public safety rsas Finance is not
prepared or experienced in dealing with
uh the the that part of our code the
public safety codes so that should have
gone to Children family law and it added
irrelevant and damaging budget
benchmarks I appreciate the engineer who
brought it forward but in the bringing
it Forward at the last minute these were
not the right benchmarks we we we cited
something called the uh prison rape
elimination act which is which is not
appropriate to this and we also cited a
benchmark that said that we should use
the average of the nation
we are leading the nation in what we're
doing the nation should be following us
we shouldn't be looking at what the
nation does and just be average because
we're already beating them they need to
do what we're doing so that part should
not have been in there it should have
gone to Children family law
um
so in the public safety area there were
unintended consequences with what got
offered and I heard you know the the
gentlelady speaking earlier talking
about this we all care about these kids
but that what will happen if we narrow
the scope
precipitously and without a real hearing
we're going to have unintended
consequences there'll be fewer
diversions right now kids can be
diverted 72 percent of the children
assessed by dcyf were recommended for
diversion and because this is a credible
process based on this this check mark or
checklist law enforcement has agreed
with that recommendation 94 percent of
the time so so our system is working
don't change it
this amendment or the the one that we
just voted on
added that three active charges need to
be open at any one time to send somebody
to the the youth center
think about that what what happens in
the real world if you have to have if
your law enforcement responsible for
Public Safety and you have to have three
active charges that means you're not
willing to defer charges that means you
have to push forward with as many
charges as you can because the kids that
end up at the youth center are not new
to the system
they will be sent to the this future
system intended by this amendment to a
health care setting to where their
behavioral and mental health needs can
be further Ada addressed and of course
it's secure because some of these kids
have done some you know are alleged to
have done some pretty heinous things so
it has to be secure
there will be fewer plea Bargains
because the amendment that we just voted
on requires a higher level of charges to
be considered that means
the judges will be less likely to reduce
the charges so this is going to hurt
kids because they're going to get
overcharged and they won't get stuff
deferred and the recommendations of dcyf
will be ignored so with all of that
I just want to say
that I'm requesting you to pass this
floor Amendment because it adds a
critical part B to what we've already
done relative to sb1 it's just
completing our homework finally let's do
that I would ask you to vote for this
amendment because it takes out the part
C to send it over to children and family
law where it belonged in the first place
and who it's not me saying this not me
this is an agreement by the Department
of Health and Human Services the
signatories of that letter include the
commissioner the dcyf director the
behavioral health director it's signed
by the New Hampshire legal assistance by
Elisa Cannon the executive director of
the New Hampshire Juvenile Court
division Network signed by Waypoint new
Futures Lynn Chalet of the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence
more people who want this amendment
include Karen Rosenberg the policy
director of the disability rights Center
of New Hampshire the children's Law
Center of New Hampshire Rich Gula the
president of the state employees
Association Naomi New Hampshire
Marsha rezmar sink of Casa New Hampshire
that's the court appointed special
Advocates so the organization that deals
with the court appointed Advocates is on
board with this floor Amendment Michael
guia the president of the New Hampshire
Police Association the juvenile
lots of murmurs I'm almost done but
these people have worked for two years
very hard on this and I just want them
recognized the Juvenile Justice Reform
Commission both the chair and the vice
chair signed it the oversight Commission
on children's services that four people
signed that from to include Sharon
Carson Senator Carson the chair Senator
Whitley the vice chair that's
nonpartisan agreement uh Mary Ellen
McKay The Honorable Mary Ellen McKay
who's the executive director for the New
Hampshire Foster and adoptive parents
Renee Tui Childress of the Dover
Children's Home The dcyf Advisory Board
eight people from that signed eight and
that includes obviously Mike Adams
adomski the board chair then the granite
state Children's Alliance signed and
last but not least
our own New Hampshire Office of the
child advocate Cassandra Cassandra
Sanchez all of these people have agreed
to pass this amendment so let's please
now it's our turn let's do what they've
asked please vote in support of this
floor amendment to complete the work of
sb1 avoid another Committee of
conference disaster return the new
policy questions over to Children and
Family Law what's their jurisdiction and
allow New Hampshire to continue to lead
the nation let's not be mediocre let's
do this right this is policy and not
politics Mr Speaker I asked for a roll
call so that the community knows who to
send thank you notes to
and this is not politics please vote
green thank you
Zen
well remember yield no question
it's rather unexpected but yes I will
remember yields because this is all
about professional courtesy today that's
right
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative for bringing this
amendment forward and also for taking my
question so my question is
can you tell us how this amendment
prevents children from being prosecuted
at higher levels
and out of lockdown so how are we
preventing kids from being prosecuted at
higher levels through this
so I'll I'll tell you what the experts
the people who live and breathe in this
space have told me to include the the
advocates for these kids to include the
legal system the the police and the
judges what they had said is that if we
go with what we just voted on what will
happen is it will because three active
charges are needed all of a sudden the
just judicial system will not want to do
what it's doing now what it's doing now
is it's deferring charges in lieu of
community-based services
it's pleading down charges knowing that
if they still need to they can get
somebody into the system and those are
really the the two key things that
happen because we have this
dysfunctional requirement that there has
to be three active charges for somebody
who may be dangerous to be sent to the
center so given that this is a
therapeutic center I think we'd rather
have some somebody who may be dangerous
sent to where they could get some
counseling and support and hopefully get
their lives straight before it really
gets started as an adult but thank you
for the question because remember yield
to further questions I know further no
further well the member the member
that's my go ahead
the member does a member yield to
further questions I I I do yes sir thank
you the member May inquire
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you very
much representative Edwards my question
is um I'm Sherry Gould
Merrimack District 8 and former director
of the Antrim girl shelter and
alternative to lock up for adolescent
females in New Hampshire in Antrim New
Hampshire my question to you is other
than the guests we have in the galley
there's a list of names you gave us do
you know of any other experts or
Professionals in New Hampshire that can
fix our broken system
it's five words other than the experts
you name do you know any other people in
New Hampshire who can fix our broken
system
who
I'm still getting the key word do you
think that the people that you that are
supporting this are the right people to
fix our system do you know of any others
I I know of no others I know of an
advocate who who lost the job because
they took the wrong position two years
ago and got replaced with somebody who's
on board with this so I don't know of
anyone that's in the community who's a
professional who works this issue who
opposes this amendment the the support
is overwhelming
thank you as a member yield to further
questions no further questions thank you
member but does not yield
representative Edwards has requested a
roll call as that's efficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the most members should be in the
Estates
the motion before us is the Edwards
floor Amendment
1104 H this is a roll call vote Gia
recognizes to represent a pool for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know
that The Advocates that signed that
letter and I agree how important it is
to treat these children differently
further know that the amendment we
adopted before from the committee
already does that
if I know that there's a portion of the
amendment we're looking at in section
four
that sets the 150 acres over or gives
150 acres over to das to sell
approximately 600 buildable Lots
that doesn't need to be in this
amendment right now
would I vote no on 1104 H so that we can
keep with the committee Amendment and
pass the Bill thank you
jerich and as representative Lynn for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that the version of
this bill as it was approved by the
finance committee uh and now approved by
this body a few minutes ago incorporates
an amendment that I proposed in
consultation with the representative
from where who was vice who served as
Vice chair of finance and if I know that
that Amendment contains terms extraneous
to what is necessary for the
construction and operation of a new
Youth Development Center incorporating
the trauma-informed care that everybody
agrees to and if I know that those
extraneous terms narrow the offenses for
which miners may be committed to the new
facility
and if I know that although the intent
of the proponents of these extraneous
terms was to protect minors from
inappropriate detention and commitment
at such facility
the overwhelming consensus of both state
and local officials who work with
children and a broad range of children's
Advocates groups is that the current law
regarding the crimes for which juveniles
may be committed is working well and has
resulted representative this is a
parliamentary inquiry I'm sorry thank
you Mr Speaker has resulted in our
having the lowest number of people of
children from any state in the country
and if I know that in drafting the
amendment that was ultimately adopted by
the finance committee my purpose was was
not to Advocate that that amendment was
the best solution to the issues of what
crime should be the basis for commitment
of juveniles but was only offered as a
for what I would refer to as a less bad
alternative to an even worse program
than being considered by the finance
committee and finally if I know that the
amend that amend that the amendment that
is now before us proposed which was
proposed by the representative from
Auburn makes no changes to current law
regarding the offenses for which
juveniles May juvenile commitment may be
allowed and is supported by the police
DCF
and the overwhelming majority of
interest groups then would I
press the green button to adopt this
amendment thank you Mr Speaker and I
apologize for being too long
the motion before us
is the Edwards floor Amendment 1104 h
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
thank you
represental
representative tool
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will tend to
save the vote
276 voting yay 104 voting a the Edwards
Amendment passes the motion before us
now is ought to pass with Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
opposed nay
the eyes have it 276 to 104.
the house will be in order
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly faster which was deferred
House Bill 557 FN relative Department of
Health and Human Services rulemaking
Authority regarding immunization
requirements this comes to us without
recommendation
representative call fault moves ought to
pass
chair recognizes representative pelosov
thank you Mr Speaker
Horizon's support of HBO 557
the Department of Health and Human
Services is perfectly set up to enable
Public Health funding continuous
functioning and following CDC mandates
but the department is not set up to do
the proper risk benefit analysis for
your constituents uh
the department
relies on federal statistics
currently last week for example cgc
confirmed that covet vaccine caused
stroke department tells us that covet
vaccine caused myocarditis but they
still still come to us and ask to
promote this vaccination
uh four times more kids that in New
Hampshire following the covet vaccines
and after Corvette
Massachusetts death certificates show
that
tachycardia cardiac arrested
are all up more concerning that slow
developing diseases like plutonium and
life node cancers are continually
increasing following the death toll
after the covet vaccine so why it's
happening
uh uh seven year old south of Nashua a
girl received covet vaccine and then
five minutes she began throwing out and
she was going out for uh eight to ten
hours
despite that it was not reported despite
that when she became better and time
came they administered the second shot
severe pain vomiting 103 degree fever
five days after the second shot she died
will her desk help the department to
make the right decision unfortunately
not because on the death certificate
they didn't put
the right reason of course that was
covered vaccine they put should date of
covet the girl who had immediate
reaction to the first shot and immediate
reaction for the second shot
and there are a thousand cases like that
that's why Department continue his
promotion of vaccine
uh and uh
we are being told that
The Professional
but unfortunately professionals are
threatened to lose their license if they
tell anything that causes vaccine
hesitancy
so the department just is not in a good
position
to make
uh
to make decisions in in future and
that's why I ask you to support this
bill
thank you
the chair recognized representative
Murphy
thank you Mr chair and good morning all
it's not on
better
thank you Mr Speaker and good morning
all
um
House Bill 557 essentially removes the
rule-making authority of the
commissioner of DHHS
for immunization requirements Beyond
those diseases already identified in
statute
it is an attempt to eliminate through
the removal of the commissioner's
Authority recommendations from subject
matter experts in the field of medicine
and vaccine science when establishing
solid Public Health
policies
this bill would take away the necessary
flexibility of the commissioner who
needs to make real-time decisions
regarding Public Health threats
removing the Commissioners rule making
Authority may result in the delayed
response to address imminent threats to
the health of New Hampshire school
children in our communities
it is important to remember
that during the early stages of the
covid pandemic the legislature did not
meet and without the Commissioners
judicious
And Timely authority to act the health
of our children and communities would
have been compromised
preventing the spread of diseases in our
schools in our child care programs is a
vital Public Health function best
protected by keeping rule-making
Authority for immunization requirements
with the commissioner of DHHS the
commissioner and DHS DHHS engage with a
broad spectrum of clinical and
infectious disease experts and policy
makers in a very transparent process
which includes input from the public and
legislature when considering adding or
removing vaccine requirements these
decisions to add or remove vaccines are
made very infrequently and then made
only after extensive discussions with
all appropriate Health Care Experts the
legislature and the public
these decisions are not made in
isolation this process is a deliberative
and thoughtful one
with only one goal in mind the public
health safety and well-being of all
Granite Staters
actually the last time a vaccine was
added to the school list of required
vaccines was in 2003 and that was for
varicella which is commonly known known
as chickenpox and the department has
repeatedly stated
that it has no intention of adding
covid-19 vaccine or influenza vaccines
for school and child care attendance
it's also important to remember
that the commissioner's Authority does
have oversight previous legislation
established the ethics oversight
advisory committee this committee was
designed to offer guidance to the
commissioner related to ethical issues
relevant to the planning and responsive
communicable diseases including
immunizations
should the commissioner
in his or her team of experts consider
changes to the list of immunizations the
ethics oversight advisory committee
which is made up of members of both this
house and the Senate
would need to convene to rec to review
any recommendations
lastly by allowing rules requiring
varicella Hepatitis B homophilus
influenza type B vaccines to expire in
June of 2026
may have severe consequences for the
health of our children and the staff
that attend child care in school all
three of these diseases are highly
contagious and infectious in school
school-aged children and in severe cases
can result in permanent disability or
even death
this would actually leave New Hampshire
as the only state in the nation that
does not have a requirement for
varicella or hemophilus influenza B
vaccines
the existing Statute in responding and
corresponding administrative rules are
appropriate for allowing external input
reinforcing the relationship between
executive and legislative powers to
balance and protect parental choice
and protect the health of all children
enrolled in New Hampshire schools and
day care facilities
colleagues I appreciate that this bill
may have been in response to the covet
pandemic but to insist that the entire
legislature with no medical expertise
would emergently convene during a an
emerging Public Health crisis in order
to decide an appropriate course of
action would delay and compromise the
health of many children and our
communities
I am a physician and I practiced
Orthopedics for orthopedic surgery in
this state for 40 years
however I do not feel that I have the
requisite Baseline clinical knowledge
nor do I want or seek the legislative
authority to make critical decisions
regarding vaccine policy
infectious disease management in the
middle of an epidemic or public health
decisions of any consequence therefore I
urge you to vote no on the ought to pass
motion so that these decisions are left
to the subject matter experts the member
will suspend for a minute
it's getting awful loud in here the
member has a right to be heard if you
have to have a conversation take it out
into any room
remember they continue
thank you Mr Speaker and I asked for a
division vote thank you
I recognize your representative McDonald
thank you Mr Speaker for your thought
representative representative Senator
nataso has requested a roll call
it's not sufficiently seconded yet but I
would assume we're going to have one so
members start taking your seats quietly
remember may continue
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker the issue of whether an
executive and state government should
have extensive ability for discretionary
action it's been one of great debate in
this chamber over the last few years
this is understandable
on the one hand dangerous and uncertain
times do require a need for government
to respond quickly and efficiently
however
it is the concern over executive
Authority that gave rise to our nation
247 years ago
the debate about how much Authority an
executive should have and how and when
they should be able to exercise it will
be a debate full of the legislative and
judicial branches of government to
engage in well beyond the time that any
of us will be sitting here
there's a 23-year employee of the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services who served under the
administrations of six different
Commissioners I know that each of them
strive to do their best for our state
they acted and did seek the advice of
those around them
what we must consider as we vote for
this bill however is that public health
concerns need to be vetted by more than
a small select group
our state constitution established the
legislative branch of government as the
first Branch for an important reason
it was because it is the most
representative branch of government and
that branch of government closest to the
people
it is also the most powerful
without us and the legislation which
originates here and across the hall
nothing else tends to happen
almost everything in state government
begins and ends here
Mr Speaker it is entirely appropriate
that the legislature make the very
important decision on immunizations and
the extent of the authority of the
executive in this case the commissioner
of the Department of Health and Human
Services and I therefore urge our
colleagues to vote green for ought to
pass thank you Mr Speaker
he was in San Antonio has requested a
roll call
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
is
it
the motion before us is the honor pass
recommendation on hb557 this is a roll
call vote share recognized
representative Murphy for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
preventing the spread of diseases in our
schools in child care programs is a
vital Public Health function best
protected by keeping the rule-making
Authority for immunization requirements
with the commissioner of DHHS in his
expert team and if I know that this bill
would take away the necessary
flexibility of the commissioner who
needs to make real-time decisions in
consultation with subject matter experts
in the field of medicine in vaccine
science in order to protect the public
health safety and well-being of all
granite stateers
and finally if I know that allowing the
rules requiring varicella chickenpox
Hepatitis B or hermophilus influenza
type B vaccines to expire in June of
would have severe consequences for our
children and staff that attend child
care in school what I now push the red
button on the motion dot to pass thank
you
chair recognize representative Missouri
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know
as you know
that the Center for Disease Control has
made many mistakes in regards to
covid-19 over the past three years
and if I know that the people of New
Hampshire want more opportunity for
public input transparency and
accountability when these new vaccine
decisions are made
and finally
if I know that DHHS employees are not
elected to represent the will of the
people
but we as legislators are
would I please press the green button
thank you
the house will be in order
the motion before us is the auto pass
motion and House Bill 557 it's a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if your opposer
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
that's right
[Music]
represents your way
Representatives Dumas and Banyan
hand done representative thank you
thank you representative eulery
all members president an opportunity to
vote also attend the state of the vote
184.893 voting a motion of Water Pass
fails what Regional rise move itl
motion of itl is before us
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote everybody should be
in their seats
30 seconds
thank you
the motion before us is inexperienced
the legislator and House Bill 557 this
is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed or press a
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
representative
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 stated
the vote
194 voting a 185 voting a motion of itl
passes
majority of committee and health and
human services and elderly Affairs to
which those referred House Bill 575 FN
and act relative to vaccine and
pharmaceutical products purchased
promoted or distributed by the state and
its political subdivisions considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate said James
Murphy from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same you know don't agree
with the majority report the
recommendation to build out a pass
representative Jim cofalt for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative wheeler
I'm going to blame my friend from
Peterborough for that one
that's on you
thank you HB 575 is a cut and dry bill
it says the state of New Hampshire shall
not distribute or advertise any
pharmaceutical product or immunization
which has not been clinically tested
with voluntary human clinical trials
I support this legislation because we
have a pharmaceutical industry which has
been caught time and time again
mishandling the life-saving drugs
treatments and immunizations given to
the general population
the industry has shelled out hundreds of
billions of dollars and Anti-Trust fines
been caught knowingly over over
prescribing incredibly addictive drugs
which have destroyed our communities
broken up our families and left us
drugged out and dumb they have caught
they have been caught rushing drugs
through the trial process bluffing about
the tests carried out and a whole host
of actions which prove that these are an
industry that this is an industry which
is not to be trusted
so why should we not require the
products they give our state to be
distributed to be tested
voluntarily tested on human beings
we are in a situation right now where
products being distributed with our name
on it as a state have been tested only
on mice
I do not feel comfortable with the state
Distributing products where the efficacy
has not adequately been tested
this does not ban the distribution of a
drug not tested if you still want a
product from a company with a record
such as Pharma does that has only been
tested on mice shall be it you can take
that product
and the companies will definitely still
be Distributing it it simply says the
state will not distribute or advertise
products not adequately tested for these
companies now some of the fear-mongering
by my friends in opposition to this bill
is unfounded
we heard that you wouldn't be able to
get the flu vaccine anymore because it
isn't tested every year
the fact of the matter is the base of
the flu vaccine was tested using human
clinical trials and unless we used a
completely new vaccine
this would apply this wouldn't apply to
that bill therefore the state could
distribute the flu vaccine as much as it
wanted to it's been tested using human
clinical trials the flu vaccine will
still be available at your local
drugstore all of these vaccines will
still be available I think a simple
regulation
to the pharmaceutical industry which
time and time again has proven its
criminality a simple regulation saying
that you must test your drugs with
voluntary human clinical trials is a
basic and bipartisan thing that I think
all of us should be able to agree on in
the fact that this conversation has
become so partisan is a sad State of
Affairs thank you Mr Speaker and I ask
you to vote with me for this bill
the house will be in order
chair recognize representative Murphy
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill 575 would prohibit the state
in its political subdivisions from
purchasing promoting or Distributing any
vaccine or pharmaceutical product that
has not been tested with quote voluntary
human clinical trials
if enacted it would have potentially
wide-ranging and negative unintended
consequences
first of all the wording in the proposed
legislation is vague with very unclear
intent
human Clinical Trials come in very much
very different forms of studies focusing
sometimes on the safety of
pharmaceutical products while Others May
deal with measuring effectiveness
there are also different ways to measure
effectiveness
House Bill 575 also mandates quote
voluntary human trials
I would have you know that as specified
in federal law the use of involuntary
human subjects in clinical trials is
prohibited and considered unethical and
therefore the use of voluntary in the
context of a human clinical trial
requirement is inappropriate and
unnecessary
mandating a new clinical trial for the
periodically updated flu in pneumococcal
vaccines would delay their timely
availability for children and adults
resulted in increased morbidity in
mortality
this routine process for updating these
vaccines is very similar to that which
was done during the initial bivalent
vaccine rollout and was proven to be
very effective and safe
this bill would also lead
to increase costs for some of the
childhood vaccines you may not know this
but the New Hampshire DHHS is currently
able to purchase childhood vaccines
at a reduced cost through the vfc
program the vaccines for children
program which are then distributed to
health care providers so that the cost
of these vaccines can be minimized for
families
if the New Hampshire DHHS and other
partners were unable to promote purchase
and distribute these vaccines than cost
to individuals communities and the
overall health care System would
increase
another unfortunate in unintended
consequence would be the effect on the
FDA provision known as expanded access
commonly known as compassionate use
for those that do not know compassionate
use is a mechanism that we use to allow
patients with serious or immediately
life-threatening diseases to have access
to Medical Products including drugs
vaccines and biologics
these are products that are still
enrolled in clinical trials but in
certain desperate circumstances can be
used under compassionate use after
meeting certain criteria
a mild lateral School ALS
Muscular Dystrophy and certain cancers
are examples of this use lastly
one of the most significant consequences
of this legislation is that
DHHS would not be able to purchase and
distribute many of these routinely
recommended and life-saving vaccines
in other medical therapies to those
living in congregate settings like
Correctional Facilities nursing homes
and mental health institutions
those living in these facilities are at
significantly increased risk for
contagious diseases and this would lead
to increased morbidity mortality and
suffering
colleagues the wording intent of HB 575
is vague and unclear and the unintended
consequences noted here would lead to
compromised access to life-saving
vaccines and other Therapeutics and will
likely increase health care costs I urge
you to vote Yes on the I.T motion itl
motion and I request a division vote
thank you
just remember yielded questions
member does not yield
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
foreign
majority committee report of inexperiod
to legislate and house bill 575.
this is a roll call vote chair
recognized representative Phillips for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that informed consent is the
foundation of a fair Health Care System
would I support this legislation
and if I know that today we as
legislators can send a clear message
that we will protect Granite Staters
from becoming guinea pigs for big
pharma's future experiments and that
products tested on mice only
are not proven safe and effective enough
for New Hampshire
and if I know that taxpayers should not
be funding vaccine advertisements and
that the state of New Hampshire should
leave promotion of pharmaceutical
products to the industry itself
lastly Mr Speaker if I trust science
would I press the red button so that
another motion can be made
sure I recognize you have sent Murphy
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that mandating a new clinical trial
annually for the periodically updated
fluent pneumococcal vaccines would
significantly delay their timely
availability for children and adults
resulting in increased morbidity in
mortality
and if I know that this bill would lead
to higher patient costs for some
childhood vaccines that are now
purchased and distributed by DHHS at a
reduced cost through our vaccines for
children program
and if I know that this bill would
negatively impact the fda's
compassionate use program intended to
allow patients
with serious and immediately
life-threatening diseases to have access
to Medical Products including drugs and
vaccines and finally if I know that this
bill would compromise dhh's dhhs's
ability to purchase and distribute
life-saving vaccines and other medical
therapies to those living in congregate
settings who are at significantly
increased risk for contagious diseases
what I now push green on the motion to
itl this Bill thank you
Walsh Sherman Forest majority committee
report of inexpected legislator and
house bill 575. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're upholster press a
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
representative Weber
foreign
[Music]
92 voting a 186 voting a committee
report is adopted
Mr Speaker
member rise having voted on the
prevailing side I would move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote no
and a division please
motion before us
is reconsideration
on House Bill 575.
the vision has been requested
members still should be in their seats
representative Leachman declared a
conflict of interest and did not vote on
the last vote
the motion before us is reconsideration
and House Bill 575 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press a
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
you've got to give me yourself
representative thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also tend to stay the vote
185 voting yay 194 vote in May the
motion fails
majority of committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Fiesta which was referred House Bill 582
FN act requiring a division of Vital
Records to collect induced termination
of pregnancy to cystics having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpeding to legislators in a Lucy
Weber for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unoped agree
with the majority Report with the
following Amendment and recommendation
to Bill ought to pass with Amendment
representatively a Cushman for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative love
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you colleagues
I rise in opposition to the committee
report in expedient to legislate on
House Bill 582.
House Bill 582 has nothing to do with
prying into private medical records of
anyone and in fact House Bill 582 isn't
much different than a highway accident
statistics study
where the accidents happen under what
conditions and leading to how can we cut
down on accidents
over the last few decades New Hampshire
taxpayers have funded the Family
Planning program to the tune of several
million dollars
what was essentially been doing is the
equivalent of throwing money into the
wind and hoping it helps
if we use some of the Family Planning
funds to educate teens both male and
female now
about the consequences of unprotected
sex
we may just save them from the lifelong
mental anguish that many experience
after abortion
I had a close family close family member
to spent 28 years suffering from a
burning guilt as a result of an abortion
at the age of 14.
she had multiple suicide attempts
was institutionalized roughly 10 times
along with suffering from chronic and
severe alcoholism and drug addiction
she died at the age of 42 from uterine
cancer but in her own words
the doctors might have found that found
the cancer in time if they if they if I
had gotten my butt off the off the bar
stool
you see uterine cancer is is commonly
cured if found in time
the combination of guilt and alcoholism
killed her just as much as cancer
as legislators we have an obligation to
help young young women the young women
of New Hampshire and do all we can to
collect Anonymous information
so the tragedy of of post-abortion guilt
and all its horrific implications
can be minimized or possibly even
avoided altogether
former President Bill Clinton once said
abortions should be accessible and rare
New Hampshire needs the information that
house bill 582 will provide in order to
in order to fulfill the latter part of
the President Clinton's statement
in conclusion House Bill 582
is the anonymous Gathering of data
data that will help the young women of
New Hampshire
and again any statements the contrary
are inaccurate and untrue
please press the red button to overturn
the committee recommendation of an
expense in expedient to legislate so
another motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative Weber
nothing in this bill
will prevent
personal tragedy
what the bill will do
is that it will require providers of
induced termination of pregnancy to
collect 15 different categories of
information
about every person seeking the procedure
a magical procedure that is legal
and then to transmit that data all of it
intensely personal
de-identified but on an individualized
basis
to the New Hampshire Bureau of Vital
Statistics
much of the information required to be
collected has no relevance for the
provider
with respect to the medical care
provided
part one article 2B of the New Hampshire
Constitution passed in 2018
states that an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion in
private or personal information
is natural
essential and inherent
government inquiry into the most
personal of medical decisions and
practices such as methods of
contraception previous terminations
previous stillbirths previous births how
many children born alive still living
marital status from the time of
conception to the time of termination
educational level race and ethnicity
that's pretty personal information
and this is a small state and
de-identified information
well
what could possibly go wrong with that
the collection and transmission of this
information is an infringement of the
right to be free from governmental
intrusion guaranteed in the New
Hampshire con Constitution
and we have all learned about the risk
that that data can be re-identified and
linked to individuals
the amendment offered in committee would
change that
so that Parts would be voluntary
without any
discussion about
how that would be defined
but the facts remain first of all
this data is personal
and second if the data sought is to be
used for statistical and public health
purposes
if it was voluntary
the data wouldn't be complete and
wouldn't be very useful
finally
if import forming Public Health
decisions is the goal
the majority notes that this kind of
information is not collected about other
Medical Treatments even those other
treatments which are also intimately
entwined with maternal health and
childbirth
thank you
so
what could possibly go wrong
think about data collection think about
the data leaks you have heard of think
about your personal privacy
and vote green on the itl thank you
there's a member yielded questions
yes remember yields
let me inquire
thank you Mr speaker thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering if you
have any idea how many states do not
collect such information
[Music]
thank you
as we have often been told here this is
New Hampshire
and we do things the New Hampshire way
the house will be in order
[Applause]
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpeding to
legislate on House Bill 582.
are you ready for the question division
has been requested members take your
seats
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of index fee to
legislative House Bill 582 this is a
division vote the chair recognized
representative lay on for a
parliamentary inquiry the house will be
in order
thank you Mr Speaker if I know today
that the only people who have statistics
on abortions in New Hampshire are the
abortion providers
and if I believe that the legislature
could better allocate Family Planning
dollars if we had access to anonymized
data
and if I know that by overturning this
itl motion we will have the opportunity
to consider language on page 92 that
would allow us to provide information
requested by the CDC and allow women to
volunteer the reason why they were led
to a decision that they wish they never
had to make
and then finally Mr Speaker if I know
that the only way that we can live up to
presidents Clinton's desire for
accessible and rare abortions is to be
able to know how often we've reached
this point would I then press at the red
button thank you
do you recognize representative Weber
or a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Mr if I know
that the reasons that I have reached
any medical decision that I have reached
are none of my health care providers
business and are none of the state's
business
and if I know that that applies to every
single medical procedure that every
single one of us undergoes
would I now vote red to preserve the
privacy of every single one of us the
house will be in order or perhaps I
ought to have said green because you're
getting a rut sometimes thank you please
press the green button
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of index meeting to
legislate and house bill 582. this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button your opposal press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
foreign
I can't see representative thank you
well members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
205 voting yay 177 voting 80 committee
report is adopted
what region is to memorize
I'd like to make a motion State your
motion just move that the remarks from
the previous debate be entered in the
permanent Journal please
without objection
the majority of committee on Health and
Human Services and Elder Affairs to
which was referred House Bill 615 FN act
require an independent audits of
reproductive Health Care Facilities have
been considered the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is in its competing to legislate
representative uh Joe Shapiro from the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
be an unable to agree with the majority
report the recommendation to Bill on a
pass it's in America lay on from the
minority of the committee
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion Mr Speaker motion I move
that we lay House Bill 615 on the table
it's a proper motion the motion before
us delay House Bill 615 on the table
are you ready for the division has been
requested
the motion before is the majority
majority committed report of inexped
into legislator and House Bill 615 a
motion is to lay House Bill 615 on the
table
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your post you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
thank you
[Music]
well marriage president an opportunity
to vote house will attends state of the
vote
354 vote in yay 29 voting a the motion
delay 615 on the table
committee on Judiciary tuition for its
cacr2 relating to reproductive Freedom
providing that all persons have the
right to make their own reproductive
decisions comes to what's without
recommendations
representative Torah moves ought to pass
chair recognizes representative Lynn
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker as a person who is pro-choice
I rise in opposition to this proposed
Constitutional Amendment that would
establish a constitutional right to
quote reproductive autonomy
and provide that such right could not be
denied or infringed unless justified by
a compelling State interest achieved by
the least restrictive means
the proponents of this measure
say that all it does is let the voters
decide if there should be a right to
reproductive autonomy and ask how could
anyone be opposed to that
let the voters decide is a great sound
bite
which has a certain amount of simplistic
appeal
but look a bit more carefully and you
will see that what the voters are really
being asked to decide is completely
unclear
if this amendment were adopted what
exactly would be the Contours of the
right to quote reproductive autonomy
would such a right allow abortions up to
the moment of birth
up until a pregnancy progressed to 24
weeks and even beyond that in limited
circumstances as provided in our current
fetal Life protection act
up to 15 weeks
or up until detection of a fetal
heartbeat
when along this Continuum with the
state's interest in protecting life
become compelling
and what kinds of regulations would be
considered the least restrictive means
the proponents of cacr2 acknowledge that
they have no answers to any of these
questions
so who would determine the questions
the obvious answer is the New Hampshire
Supreme Court which is the ultimate
Arbiter of what the state constitution
means
but what will the Court's answer be to
any of these questions we have no idea
for example
excuse me for example some judges May
believe that protecting fetal life after
24 weeks is a compelling interest
while other judges may not and still
other judges may think that the state's
compelling the state's interest becomes
compelling earlier than 24 weeks and
since the New Hampshire Supreme Court
has never previously addressed abortion
issues under the state constitution
it will be ruling largely from a clean
slate
what all this means of course is that by
passing this cacr
we will effectively be throwing up our
hands and saying hey Court this issue is
too tough for us to decide you take care
of it
if the proponents of this amendment are
concerned about protecting Reproductive
Rights from being infringed by the
legislature
they could easily have proposed the
Constitutional Amendment that would have
that would have had real meaning
for example if they believe a woman
should have an unrestricted right to
abortion up until birth they could have
drafted a constitutional amendment to
say just that
instead they have proposed an amendment
with the uninformative language we have
before us
which of course allows them to say in
their report on the bill that if adopted
it would quote not necessarily conflict
with the free-to-life protection act
I respectfully submit that if this
amendment were to become law The
Advocates of of abortion on demand to
the moment of birth would be at the
courthouse door challenging the fetal
Life protection act in the blink of an
eye
but is there any reason to believe that
the court is somehow
to make decisions on these issues than
we are I submit to you that the answer
is no
and on this point let me remind you that
no less an advocate of abortion rights
than the late Ruth Ruth Bader Ginsburg
questioned the wisdom of placing the
abortion question in the hands of the
Judiciary
like unelected judges we are the branch
of government that is most accountable
to the people
if we get it wrong the voters the voters
will let us know about it soon enough at
the next election
by returning the public policy issue of
reproductive of Reproductive Rights back
to the courts this time the state courts
we will inevitably be politicizing New
Hampshire's courts
with rare exceptions the selection of
judges in New Hampshire has been
remarkably free of political drama
as I've had occasion to note before
Republican Governors have appointed
Democrats to the bench and vice versa
do we really want to create the
spectacle of Brett Kavanaugh type
judicial confirmation hearings in New
Hampshire
I submit respectfully that the fetal
Life protection act struck the right
balance between a woman's right to
choose and the state's legitimate
interest in protecting fetal life at
some later point in the pregnancy I
believe it is a balance that is
supported by the vast majority of New
Hampshire citizens
and since there is no serious threat of
altering that balance there simply is no
need for this constitutional amendment I
urge you to pass to press the red button
so that another emotion may be made and
Mr Speaker I asked for a division vote
thank you Mr Speaker
jerich and I Trump senator
thank you Mr Speaker I Rise to urge
passage of cacr2
this bill seeks to place Constitutional
Amendment question on the 2024 warrant
for all cities and towns in the state
the Amendment states that an
individual's right to personal
reproductive autonomy shall not be
denied or infringed unless justified by
compelling State interest achieved by
the least restrictive means
it would be inserted after section 2B
which added a broadly defined
right to privacy to the constitution in
2018.
before I address the elephant in the
room Regarding why we are likely talking
about amending the state constitution in
this way at this time
and I want to be clear that's a little e
non-partisan elephant that I just
referred to
I want to First focus on what the bill
actually says and does in that one
sentence
there are essentially three components
to the amendment it guarantees personal
reproductive autonomy meaning the
ability to make one's own decisions in
all aspects regarding one's reproduction
science and medicine provide us with
Incredible reproductive options
augmenting those we are born with
some serve to prevent pregnancy and yes
some to terminate pregnancy
but many Also Serve to promote pregnancy
and help create new life
the first successful in vitro fertilized
pregnancy was in 1978 and was quite
controversial then
today 1 in 50 babies born in the United
States are born using this type of
assistive reproductive therapy yet calls
to ban it remain
conversely some governments have placed
extreme limits on reproduction such as
one child rules and even forced
sterilization thus a broad-based right
is defined
second it establishes this as an
individual right meaning it grants
reproductive autonomy to all New
Hampshire residents not just women not
just during pregnancy
third and most importantly it provides
for exceptions
when justified by compelling State
interest under a strict scrutiny
standard this permits the government to
still Place necessary restrictions on
current and future practices
but only we're clearly Justified I'll
say more on that in a moment
okay now for that elephant
the last last June the U.S Supreme
Court's Dobbs V Jackson ruling
overturned the federally guaranteed
right to an abortion that had been
protected for nearly 50 years under the
established Rowan Casey decisions
that didn't make abortion illegal but
rather delegated the issue back to the
individual states
this is the first time in U.S history an
established Federal right has been
upended and given back to state
legislatures
so the vote we're about to take is
unlike any other taken in the history of
the New Hampshire house that's a big
statement
but it provides us with a unique
opportunity the opportunity for this
body to demonstrate that we live by the
words that are so often invoked in this
chamber
Liberty
Freedom autonomy
privacy
individual rights limited government
intrusion personal responsibility and
self-determination
we've just been handed an incredible
power that used to belong to the people
of this state and the first thing we
should do that we must do is offer to
give it back
there's no greater embodiment of freedom
and liberty privacy or autonomy than
decisions we make over our lives our
families and our bodies
abortion isn't the only reproductive
Freedom now in play
in his concurrence on Dobbs Justice
Thomas stated that the court has quote a
duty to correct the error of other cases
resting on the 14th Amendment under the
court same logic
specifically he cited the 1965 five
Griswold decision that guarantees the
right to access contraception
remember this is not a vote on whether
to establish this right for the people
but simply to ask them if they want this
right back or if we as legislators
should continue to hold it
here no means no
voting no means we want to keep this new
Authority without giving your
constituents a say
conversely however yes does not mean yes
passing this bill does not directly
establish this rate
it simply puts the question before the
voters and the bar for success is quite
High it will take three-fifths or sixty
percent of us to Simply pass this bill
and the other chamber must then do the
same
and even higher two-thirds or 67 percent
of Voters is then needed to ratify it on
the ballot that's very close to the
percentage that polls suggests might
support this concept so there's no
guarantee as to how such a vote would
turn out
knowing that How can any of us justify
not putting the question before them
if it passes it's not some radical new
right being established but rather a
preservation of the status quo that's
been in place for the majority of all of
our lives
I'll wrap up by addressing a few
concerns that I'm sure exist
won't this establish an unlimited right
to abortion at any point in pregnancy
will it automatically reverse the
24-week rules inserted into law last
year this is where that compelling State
interest and least restrictive means
components come in
I can't tell you what might be held as
the limits under this language I can say
that both the Roe and KC decisions
included limitations on the right to
abortion that are quite similar to
current New Hampshire law in that regard
might it end up before the New Hampshire
Supreme Court to decide most likely yes
but that's also what Dobbs handed down
to us
similar safeguards are offered by the
many constraints within which are
self-regulating medical profession
operates
it's those not new laws that have long
prevented elective late-term abortions
in our state
we've heard about terrible practices
carried out by Rogue medical providers
in other states most famously infamously
Pennsylvania
that Pennsylvania doctor is serving
three consecutive life sentences for his
actions not for violating some abortion
law but for murder
and we were told in hearings that such
practices could similarly be prosecuted
under New Hampshire law
finally
while we shouldn't pass a constitutional
amendment based on polls
the polls do show that guaranteeing
reproductive Choice has wider support
than the margins by which most of us
were elected
who are we then to say that we won't
even ask our voters to weigh in on this
so in closing let's do the Little D
Democratic thing
let's do the little C conservative thing
let's do the true Live Free or Die thing
let's pass this elegantly crafted Bill
to offer the people back their right
Mr Speaker I asked for a division vote
thank you
and Granger has requested a roll call it
is sufficiently seconded members take
your seats this will be a roll call vote
the motion before us was ought to pass
on cac-2 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative Wallace
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that passage of this constitutional
amendment by the New Hampshire voters
would establish a state constitutional
right to reproductive autonomy and Mr
Speaker if I know that the recently
enacted fetal Life protection act of
2021 as amended in 2022 provides
unrestricted access to abortion during
the first six months of pregnancy and
provides for exceptions to the post
six-month Prohibition in cases of
abnormalities incompatible with life or
with continuation of the pregnancy
threatens to result in serious risks to
the life or health of the mother and Mr
Speaker if I know that the fetal Life
protection act enjoys widespread public
support as it is now and finally Mr
Speaker if I know that the members of
this August body affirm in their
decisions as to the disposition of the
cacr would I now press the red button to
defeat the OTP motion so a motion of itl
can be made thank you Mr speaker
do you recognize
representative Lanza for a parliamentary
inquiry
you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that New Hampshire
has had a long proud bipartisan
tradition of supporting an individual's
right to make personal private Health
Care decisions and Mr Speaker if I know
that we as legislators have
unprecedented power over our
reproductive Freedom rights
and Mr Speaker if I know that as a labor
and delivery nurse I have had the
opportunity to meet women and men who
stand up for these rights as I do
including my constituents who elected me
to represent them
and Mr Speaker if I know that this cacr
will give every voter the opportunity to
register their opinion on this matter
would you now press the green button
thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass
and cacr-2 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposer press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
foreign
state of the vote
193 vote Eda 191 voting a the motion
fails
because of lack of three risks
during the committee on Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 68 FN
enact adopting the uniform property
transfer on death act having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation to Bill ought to password
Amendment Senator Caitlin qatab for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolve that is in
expedient to legislate presenter Rebecca
Macbeth from the minority committee the
amendment is
0436h printed in house record 16 Pages
56 through 60. are you ready for the
question on the amendment all those in
favor of the Amendments AI
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is on a
password Amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
there's a bosnay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
representative
committee on Judiciary to which was
deferred House Bill 88 relative to
Reproductive Rights
representative page moves ought to pass
the chair recognizes representative
Christine Perez
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill 88 adds no value
the existing statute allows all women
the freedom to exercise their right to
their private decisions to terminate a
pregnancy
this right is apparent in the existing
rsas
that are stated as exceptions
in House Bill 88 a public policy would
add no value
this bill has
potential
of creating a fantasy situation
that there is no evidence of
the present law
says that you can not have you can says
you cannot you can have an abortion
if there is no law preventing a crime
then there is no crime example
example
there is no law stating I cannot hike
Mount Washington
therefore if a law or officer law
enforcement officer
arrested me for hiking Mount Washington
it would have no merit and be thrown out
there is no law that says you have to
wear a yellow shirt on Fridays therefore
you cannot be arrested for wearing a
blue shirt on Friday
we do have a law
that allows women to exercise their
rights as stated in the existing rsas
and therefore they are protected of this
right
there is no evidence that the existing
law would infringe on a woman's right to
terminate a pregnancy I urge you to vote
no on ought to pass by pushing the red
button thank you chair recognize
representative Simpson
thank you Mr Speaker
I rise in support of the ought to pass
motion on hb88
hb88 does one thing it adds statutory
protections for abortion before 24 weeks
it does not change the 24-week abortion
ban
while there are other bills today to
amend that abortion law hb88 does not do
that
the purpose of this bill is to clarify
the intent of this legislature
in 2021 the 24-week abortion ban passed
into state law
as part of that law RSA 329 49 states
nothing in this subdivision shall be
construed as creating or recognizing a
right to abortion
in other words the 24-week abortion ban
did not guarantee abortion protections
prior to that cut off in fact the
opposite is true there is only an RSA
stating that there is no right to an
abortion in New Hampshire
last June the U.S Supreme Court
overturned The Landmark decision in Roe
v Wade without Roe v Wade there is no
longer a federal constitutionally
protected right to abortion
with our 24-week abortion ban there are
also no State statutory protections for
abortions prior to 24 weeks
HBA hb88 adds critical protections prior
to 24 weeks prohibiting the state from
interfering with a woman's access to
abortion in the first 23 weeks
with Rogue on New Hampshire is one of
only three states where abortion is
legal but not protected
since the ruling in June 2022 18 states
have passed abortion bans with 14 states
banning abortion outright as of today 25
million people have been impacted
already
with one in three women of reproductive
age across the country losing access to
abortion in her home state
Granite State Granite Staters have seen
these states banning abortion and they
want us their elected representatives to
take action to protect abortion rights
here
specifically polling immediately after
the election shows that a super majority
of granite Staters value the right to an
abortion and nearly two-thirds of
granite Staters want their
representatives to pass laws to support
abortion rights
I have heard my colleagues say there
will be no more restrictions on abortion
and Reproductive Rights in New Hampshire
but how can the voters trust that this
body changes every two years I'm asking
us today to Simply add in the
protections to our state law prior to 24
weeks HB 88 is a win-win today we can
send a message to Granite Staters a
clear purposeful message that the New
Hampshire house supports and affirms an
individual's right to an abortion and
the tenets of Roe v Wade
please join me in supporting the ought
to pass motion on hb88
thank you
representative Granger has requested a
roll call as that's officially seconded
it is
it is not sufficiently seconded
division has been requested this will be
a division vote
thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 88. this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative
Alexander for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know last term New Hampshire house came
together in a bipartisan Manner and
passed a law that upheld our basic
values regarding this issue on a
unanimous bipartisan vote and if I know
our current law satisfies and represents
a majority of granite State's view on
abortion
and lastly if I acknowledge the truth
that Granite Staters identify as
pro-choice but I also know that over
two-thirds of granite stators support
some restrictions on abortion would I
now press the red button to oppose the
OTP on this unnecessary Bill thank you
do you recognize right from page for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I believe this legislature intends to
ensure women in New Hampshire have
statutory protections to access abortion
care in the first 23 weeks of a
pregnancy without government
interference
and if I know that this bill does not
change anything in our law after those
23 weeks of pregnancy
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
since the Supreme Court overturned Roe
New Hampshire is one of only three
states that has not codified protections
for abortion under state law and the
majority of our constituents are looking
to us to change that beginning today
would I now press the green button
the motion before us is ought to pass in
House Bill 88 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button if your opposal press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative
thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend a state of the vote
199 148 185 voting a
committee report is adopted
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 224fn repealing a
criminal and civil penalties from the
fetal Life protection act comes to us
without recommendation Senator Marjorie
Smith's moves on a pass chair recognizes
representative Lynn
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
colleagues the basic question you must
decide in voting on this bill is whether
there should be a special exception for
doctors and other health care providers
that exempts them from the usual
remedies and sanctions the law provides
for unlawful conduct
I submit the answer should be no which
is why I urge you not to support this
bill
this would be this bill would repeal the
civil and criminal remedies
provisions of the fetal Life protection
act
the Civil remedies section allows
certain persons including the mother and
in some cases the father or maternal
grandparents to obtain monetary damages
against health care providers for
psychological and physical injuries
caused by an abortion performed in
violation of the ACT
I intend to focus mainly on the criminal
penalties provision of the ACT since
that is the section that has generated
the most angst among some members of the
medical community
it is important to understand at the
outset that performing an abortion with
the consent of the mother does not
constitute a homicide or assault type
offense under the general criminal laws
of this state
thus without the criminal penalties
provided in the fetal Life protection
act performing an unlawful post-20 week
24-week abortion would carry no criminal
sanctions
because an understanding of the exact
terms of the criminal penalty provision
of the fetal Life protection act is
crucially important let me Begin by
quoting it
any health care provider who knowingly
performs or induces an abortion in
violation of this subdivision
and knows that the fetus has a
gestational age of at least 24 weeks or
consciously disregards a substantial
risk that the fetus has a gestational
age of at least 24 weeks shall be guilty
of a class B felony the key words in the
above section are knowingly and
consciously disregards
knowingly means actual knowledge
not should have known or mere negligence
or even recklessness but actual
knowledge that the fetus was at least 24
weeks old and knowledge as well that
there were no circumstances that would
make the abortion fall within the
exceptions to the 24-week ban
the consciously disregards language of
the statute is designed to cover the
circumstance of what the law often terms
willful blindness
that is the situation of a health care
provider who claims not to have had
actual knowledge but where the evidence
shows he or she lacks such not lacks
such knowledge only because the pro
provider made a conscious deliberate
decision to close his eyes
so as to avoid or disregard learning
what was obvious that there was a
substantial risk the fetus was at least
24 weeks of gestational age
in short the criminal penalty comes into
play Only In the case of a doctor who
makes a knowing conscious decision to
violate the law and there is nothing
unfair or unjust about imposing criminal
sanctions against the health care
provider who flouts the law in this
fashion
just as we would do against any other
person who knowingly violates the law
the opponents of the penalty penalties
Advanced two basic arguments first they
claim that no health care provider in
New Hampshire ever performs post 24-week
abortions that would violate the statute
they say that such abortions occur only
in circumstances where there is a
serious threat to the life or health of
the mother or where there is a fatal
fetal abnormality and these abortions
are allowed under the fetal Life
protection act
the short answer to this argument is
that if there if that is true then
Health Care Professionals have nothing
to worry about because there will simply
be no criminal prosecutions
the problem of course is that although
we would like to believe that no health
care professional would deliberately
violate the law
we have we have seen uh both in the
abortion context and in other contexts
such as prescribing drugs we're not
medically indicated that Health Care
Providers do sometimes violate the law
the second argument advanced in
opposition to the criminal penalties is
that complicated cases can arise
in which Health Care provide
professionals are required to make
difficult judgment calls and they should
not be inhibited from doing so by the
prospect of later being held criminally
or civilly liable there is no doubt that
doctors often are required to deal with
complicated cases and to make difficult
decisions
but the requirement of engaging in
knowingly unlawful conduct affords
Health Care Providers substantial
protection against being prosecuted for
mere errors in judgment even in
circumstances where with the benefit of
hindsight they perhaps should have acted
differently in this regard please
remember that the health care providers
are not the only professionals who are
called upon to handle complicated
situations and to make difficult
judgments
consider two examples the lawyer or
accountant called upon to attest to the
accuracy of a Securities filing and the
police officer who must decide whether
to use deadly force
in both of these cases the facts and
circumstances may be complicated and in
the latter case the officer may have to
make a split-second decision
yet the prospect that there can be close
calls and difficult cases does not mean
that the lawyer the accountant or the
police officer are exempt from pla from
facing criminal and civil penalties if
they intentionally commit fraud or
knowingly use excessive force in these
cases the mere Prospect of a loss of
license or decertification as a police
officer is not considered a sufficient
sanction the law should be no different
for Health Care Professionals the
possibility of loss of a medical license
is not a sufficient sanction for
knowingly violating the law for these
reasons I urge you to reject the the OTP
motion on this bill by pressing the red
button so that another motion can be
made and Mr Speaker I respectfully asked
for a division vote thank you
I recognize Trump sin of wolf
thank you Mr Speaker and fellow
colleagues for listening to me
I rise in support of the OTP Mass motion
on House Bill 224 a straightforward bill
that would only remove the criminal
penalties on doctors and health care
providers I want to assure my colleagues
if and when we repeal this bill there
are other avenues that already exist to
ensure provider compliance with our laws
including the oplc the Board of Medicine
and criminal charges for assault and
battery oh thank you
to repeat
if we believe in the fetal protection
act there are no further changes that
will occur the 24-week abortion stays in
place
but it so often happens
there are unintended consequences with
these penalties and we've heard directly
from doctors and nurses across the state
including Dartmouth
criminal penalties discourage providers
from relocating to New Hampshire to
practice
this reduces the availability of Highly
specialized providers
two weeks ago we received news that the
11th Hospital in our state that was
providing Labor and Delivery Services
has closed there will be another one
closing this year
another birth center is has moved out of
state
we need to do everything we can to
attract and retain Health Care Providers
not deter them from coming here
a further reduction in train maternal
fetal medicine and neonatologist means
there are fewer people to take care of
all of us our wives our daughters our
sisters and our children
these criminal penalties also discourage
medical students and residents from
training in our state the chair of
Obstetrics and Gynecology at Dartmouth
Dr Alana Cass said this explicitly
during the Committee hearing a little
more
then we could excuse me a month ago that
residents stay at their medical school
generally after graduation
so if our laws discovered
students from coming to New Hampshire
then we are adding more difficulty to
increasing them
patients should expect our providers to
provide the best clinical care not
Health Care restricted by complications
of criminal or civil penalty
again there are already systems in place
to address compliance we do not need to
have added penalties
I know you've heard the facts about why
we need more doctors and if we truly
believe in the fetal protection act we
need to grow and not reduce the number
of doctors that are providing Obstetrics
and Gynecology services
and if I can hold myself together I'd
like to share a story that happened
as we were as my daughter was being
treated at Plymouth Hospital during her
pregnancy 10 months ago
she was entering the last days of her
pregnancy when she felt something was
going wrong
within an hour she was at the hospital
and her doctor had performed an
emergency cesarean section a hospital
that was still open in the North country
the baby was born with its umbilical
cord wrapped around its neck four times
the baby survived because she didn't
have to drive an hour to Dartmouth or an
hour and a half to Boston
we cannot allow the decline in good
medical services to put our daughters
at risk
we should not have Draconian threats
hanging over our doctors
we should work to encourage more doctors
to come to New Hampshire and do their
life-saving work
and please join with me
in passing HB 224 so that more of our
grandfathers and grandmothers can bounce
a baby on their knees please press the
green button
representative Granger has requested a
roll call that is sufficiently seconded
members take their seats
thank you
the motion before us has ought to pass
on House Bill 224.
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Lynn for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill would create a
special rule for health care providers
exempting them from liability for
knowingly violating the laws of this
state and if I know that no other
professions or occupations that are
required to handle complicated
situations or make difficult decisions
are afforded such special protections
and if I know that the Criminal Intent
provisions of the fetal Life protection
act affords Health Care Professionals
protection from being prosecuted for
mere good faith errors of judgment and
even for negligent or Reckless conduct
requiring instead proof of a knowing or
conscious intention to violate the law
and if I also know that as with other
professionals the mere Prospect of loss
of license does not constitute an
adequate sanction for intentional
violation of the law then what I now
press the red button to defeat the opp
motion so that another emotion can be
made thank you Mr Speaker
do you recognize representative Nagel
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that HB 224 is actually a
pro-life Bill about patient care both
mother and child and not about politics
and if I
and if I as a physician with very
painful personal experience know that
the threat of criminal penalties have
the unintended consequences of actually
putting the women and the baby's life at
risk by potentially delaying appropriate
care
and if I know that highly qualified
Obstetricians especially those who
practice in high-risk pregnancies will
not practice in New Hampshire because of
this existing statute aggravating an
already problematic labor shortage
and furthermore that I know that there's
already more appropriate systems in
place to ensure that doctors are legally
compliant
and finally
I would like to know that not one of you
would like to be responsible for your
daughter or your granddaughter not being
able to find an obstetrician to manage
her high-risk pregnancy
unnecessarily putting the life of your
granddaughter or great granddaughter at
risk then I would strongly suggest you
press the green button for OTP thank you
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 224 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you approach will press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
representative Davis can you put that
down thank you
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
205 voting a 178 40 May
committee report is adopted I'm asking
everyone to stay in your seats we have
two more bills that have just no debates
and just pis so let's get through them
and if everyone who stays in your seats
we can do it pretty quickly
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred
House Bill 261 authorizing residential
tenants to deter to terminate their
lease in instances of domestic violence
or following a disability illness or
accident
representative Manos moves ought to pass
this is going to be a division vote
chair recognizes
chair recognizes representative
Stapleton
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill punishes a
landlord with unreasonable loss of
tenancy
for tenant circumstances and situations
not have his doing and Beyond his
control
and if I know that this bill makes an
escape patch for domestic violence as
linked to RSA 173 B colon 1.
with nine categories
one of which being cruelly to animals in
subsection h
all to which there are already remedies
in law elsewhere
and if I know that this bill further
enables release
for disabling illnesses or accident
without further definition
limits or qualification
thereby opening the door for almost any
degree of disability claim
in a subjective assertion
and if I know that in a tight housing
market such an imposition by law
introduces and supersedes the lease
contract
and puts further strain on the housing
shortage
meaning delay for the landlord to
remarket the unit
and as well for the tenant to find other
abode
would I now therefore press the red
button to defeat this OTP motion so that
another motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker
do you recognize representative Divine
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill 261
recognizes that there are multiple
victims of domestic violence both the
abused tenant and landlord who stand to
lose a lot
and if I know that a valid order of
protection or a documentation evidencing
a criminal charge of domestic abuse
based on a police report is required
reflecting that the tenant or household
member adult or child
was subject to abuse and lastly if I
know that house bill 261 protects the
rights of the landlord by requiring rent
payment for the full month in which the
tenancy terminates as well as any
previous outstanding obligations would I
then press the green button to support
ought to pass
thank you Mr Speaker and I'd appreciate
your vote
thank you
you might wait a while
the motion before us is ought to pass on
House Bill 261 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposal press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
members president had an opportunity to
vote house will attend a state of the
vote
193 voting yay 191 voting May
the committee report is adopting Mr
Speaker
what reason memorized Havoc voted on the
prevailing side I'd like to move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote no
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 261.
I heard a division this will be a
division vote members should be still in
their seats
hole has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 261. this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed or press
the red button go any stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative property Miller okay
another report to Yellow
well members president an opportunity to
vote also attend state of the vote
190 voting a
1949 reconsideration fails
please stay in your seats we're down
this is going to be a roll call vote
and all we got is pis
committee on Judiciary to which it was
referred House Bill 271 FN repealing the
fetal Life protection act comes an out
recommendation representative Macbeth
moves ought to pass
president has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members stay in your
seats
foreign
forces ought to pass on House Bill 271.
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative gutab
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
abortion is currently legal in New
Hampshire through six months and beyond
for fatal fetal anomalies and if I know
that this bill legalizes purely elective
abortions of viable healthy babies at
eight months and 15 days and that this
is the most extreme position possible
and no sensible person can support that
would I now press the red button
the chair recognized representative
Macbeth for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
I know that current New Hampshire law
criminalizes and gags medical providers
such as oncologists from discussing and
delivering all the appropriate health
care options to their patients that have
been diagnosed with a devastating cancer
diagnosis if they are 24 weeks of
pregnant or more and if I know that New
Hampshire law criminalizes and prevents
emergency responses emergency responders
excuse me an emergency room medical
providers from discussing and delivering
all appropriate options for medical care
for an individual
that has suffered traumatic injuries
from an accident or suffering a
life-threatening infection or congestive
heart failure liver failure if they
happen to be 25 four weeks of pregnant
or more
and if I know that the New Hampshire
Constitution states an individual's
rights to live free from government
intrusion in private and personal
information
is a natural and essential and inherent
right would I now push the green button
to repeal these restrictions thank you
the motion before us was ought to pass
in house bill 271. this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposal press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
foreign
if all members present an opportunity to
vote
house will attend the state of the vote
192 for the house will be in order
192-192
I did vote to create the tide for what
reason does the member rise
I moved a table house bill 271.
the motion is the table house bill 271.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
Paul's May
the eyes have it and 271 is laid on the
table
we have one more Bill there is no debate
so please stay in your seats
the committee on judiciary
the committee on Judiciary to which was
referred House Bill 562 FN an act
requiring informed consent prior to
receiving an abortion procedure having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate Senator Scott
Wallace for the committee are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
that was opposed nay
the eyes have it in the committee report
is adopted
all right we're going to take our lunch
now
it uh let's say
we'll be back here please
thank you
foreign
when I stand up
is
this
before
thank you
foreign
all right
thank you
members take your seats
foreign
committee on Judiciary to which was
referred Health Bill 591 FM and that
prohibiting abortions after detection of
fetal heartbeat consider the same report
the same with the
following resolution that is inexpedient
to legislate Senator Caitlin catab
or for the committee chair recognizes
representative testerman
thank you Mr speaker thank you
apparently reps
this is a fairly simple bill
but I'm sure a few of you don't agree
with me
can you hear me
ah
this is a fairly simple bill
but
it has a few
changes or a few points in it that I'm a
few I'm sure a few of you may disagree
the
Constitution
right in the front part says
we enjoy the life enjoy and defending
life and Liberty
uh this is and that's what this is all
about
uh fetal heart is a a point in
conception or in gestation it's fairly
easy to figure out it's not 24 weeks
which are sort of arbitrary but it's you
know it's X number of days into the
brief and it's a time at which it would
be easy for somebody to determine
and the feet of Life basically says if
you can hear the heartbeat
you don't abort
fairly simple fairly straightforward
thank you
chair recognize chair recognize
representative Moulton
thank you Mr Speaker
some of you know that I am a registered
nurse and some of you might know that I
have a degree in Biochemistry
so I want to do a little bit of a
science lesson
so the
I'll wait for people to finish speaking
it's too loud in here remember has a
right to be heard thank you
so the human heart uh it beats based on
two particular ions sodium and potassium
sodium carries a one plus charge
potassium carries a two plus charge
um sodium is the greatest extracellular
ion so outside of the cell
potassium is the greatest intra ion
intracellular ion inside the cell okay
on our cellular membranes is a sodium
potassium pump
as you probably remember
things move from greatest concentration
to lesser concentration
naturally
so it uses the pump to pump like against
the flow so to speak
though the flow of those ions is what
makes your heart beat
and if you remember maybe from physics
class
electricity moves from positive to
negative and I already said that those
ions have a positive charge
so in other words moving those ions
causes a Beat
okay this is uh this is a molecular
process
when you have a petri dish
and you have cardiac cells that have
developed and they are separate in the
petri dish
then they beat separately
if you move them together this this
part's really cool if you move them
together
then the ions affect each other and they
all will be together and then you can
separate them again and they will still
beat separately it's pretty cool
actually
so all of that to say that
electricity is a molecular process it is
based on ions
it is not an indication of life
thank you
[Music]
also be in order
chair recognized representative sellers
thank you Mr Speaker before I forget
this is the heartbeat bill
I've said it before on committee I'm
saying it again right now you can feel
your own heart beating you know you're
alive
all right without that heart beating we
all know we need an EMT here or a
doctorate to try to get it back going
again
is it electrical device sure isn't it I
have to even I have to admit our bodies
are wonderfully made it's it's ingenious
you think about it and starting from
the womb or actually even before the
woman when the baby is actually in the
womb and when that gets to my point here
when does life start
you just heard it's you know it's an
electrical signal okay fine
but someone created that electrical
signal we didn't create it and I don't
think we know how to create the egg or
the or the seed yet either
until we do someone else has created
that
now at this point life we can all do we
can all come up to a point and say when
does Life Begin
does it begin at the birth the actual
birth
at six months
you know at any place between the
heartbeat in six months is it conception
how about is it even before conception
because I could read you a
piece of literature
that will actually show you a state
that's 3 500 years old
and states that you every one of us here
were known before we were even
thought of being
coming to the conception
every one of us and think of this right
now every one of us are here for this
moment
this may and you have you guys and I
have to say ladies guys sorry excuse me
I have to say
many of you have many more years than I
do in this Great Hall
but we're here to try to do what's right
for the people in New Hampshire
thank you
at this point because we don't count how
many abortions we do
shame on us we try to get a billion pass
today we couldn't even do that
but because we don't count we have to
kind of kind of go by estimates
so think of the estimates out there
two thousand a year abortions that are
done
20 years that's 40 000.
human beings that are no longer here
but if they were hey our schools would
actually be full instead of declining
those people that we actually need to
work and jobs would actually have them
but instead they're not here
so let me bring up another fact
another fact or at least I believe it is
deception you know let's look at
Deception for a second
I had to go and look it up because you
know I'm not an English major
but and I like to know things that I say
are truthful
and it says so what is deception it's an
act or statement that misleads hides the
truth or promotes belief
uh concept
idea that is not true
or an idea that is not true
it is often done for personal gain or
advantage
deception can be involved and
propaganda
slight sleight of hand
distraction camouflage and concealment
you get the point deception
I believe
and I believe with all not just women I
think the men as well our entire
New Hampshire the people of New
Hampshire the people of the United
States the people around the globe have
been deceived deceived that abortion is
not
killing or aborting a baby
all right because we're saying hey
abortion starts this time abortion
starts that time it doesn't I believe
that we've been deceived to think that
abortion starts at this time of that
time
but at this at this point here I'm going
to leave this because I can keep going
on and on and I don't want to keep
taking the whole day up because we got
some more bills right
but I also believe you are here at this
time this day this moment for this vote
in history
that's being recorded
even if we don't record it on a roll
call it's being recorded
to stand up for life
and I'll leave you this one quote
For You O God created my inner being you
knit me together in my mother's womb
I praise you because I am fearfully and
wonderful made
your works are wonderful I know that
because well your eyes saw my unform
body
all the days ordained for me were
written in your book
before one of them came to be before one
of them ever came to be
keep them and written down
and lastly I apologize One Last Thing
I will bring up
this is what I'm selling today believe
it or not
I mean Proverbs 23 23.
buy the truth and sell it not
also wisdom and instruction and
understanding
I'm telling you the truth and I'm not
even charging you for it
thank you I hope we're having a division
vote at least
representative Granger has requested a
roll call and not sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
take your seats
thank you
motion before us is the committee report
of inexpeding to legislate and House
Bill 591 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative sellers for a
parliamentary inquiry
again thank you Mr Speaker
if I had known
that this vote by pressing I believe
that the red button to get rid of this
itl and make another motion if I had
known
that I'd be saving lives I would
definitely vote that red button
the other thing if I have known
that would say any heartbeat
that one is alive I would press that red
button
thank you
chair recognize representative Alexander
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker I feel like a
broken record today
if I know last term New Hampshire house
came together in a bipartisan Manner and
passed a law that upheld our basic
values regarding this issue on a
unanimous bipartisan vote and if I know
our current law satisfies and represents
majority of granite Staters views on
abortion and lastly Mr Speaker if I
acknowledge the truth that Granite
Staters identify as pro-choice but also
know that over two-thirds of granite
series support some restrictions on
abortion when I now press the green
button thank you
the motion before us is the committee
report of inexperienced a legislator and
house bill 591. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed press the
red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
had an opportunity to vote house attend
the state of the vote
271 voting yay 110 voting a committee
reporters adopted
committee on labor industrial a little
bit of services which are referred House
Bill 150 relative to certification of a
collective bargaining unit comes without
recommendation representative Sullivan
moves on a pass the chair recognize the
representative infantine
thank you Mr Speaker
House Bill 150 has to do with the amount
of individuals needed to create a
bargaining unit
it has been 10 individuals since 1975.
you'll see on the
report on page 39 the chronology of of
this law
we had one group come to us
complaining that they had six
individuals
and those individuals could not create
their own bargaining unit
so they wanted to reduce the amount of
individuals needed from ten to five
those individuals were able to join a
union they joined a different Union
within that municipality
so they were not
voided of the ability to join a union
the group then went to complain that
well yeah but it wasn't our Union and
they didn't provide good enough wages or
safety
so for that reason that Union wasn't
good enough and they should join our
Union
as I said it's been 10 for a number of
years and why has it been that way well
in my city in Manchester they have
full-time people that deal with the
unions the union bargaining and Union
negotiating and that's fine but some
other smaller towns don't have that
luxury they don't have the financing to
do that they can't afford to have a
large number of very small unions so
they group them together and it makes it
easier for those towns to negotiate and
there is a cost associated with it
without question this is a a compromise
that was made
um
to try to satisfy the certain number of
people to create a bargaining group with
the cost of associated of the cost
associated with doing that
as I said this has been a law since
1975.
and I believe it should stay where it is
and no one was disenfranchised here no
one was not allowed to join a union
so I respectfully ask you to um
to vote against the the uh ought to pass
go for a further motion
chair recognizer representative Sullivan
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker hb150 is a very
straightforward bill
at present RSA 273a requires that in
order to have a certification vote for a
new bargaining unit
in in the public sector that is that
potential unit must have at least 10
employees who would be part of that
bargain unit
hb150 reduces that number to a five
employee minimum
passing hb150 will open the door to
collective bargaining for employees who
For No Good Reason have been denied this
privilege up until now
the 10-member minimum in current law is
truly an arbitrary number
there is no identifiable reason why
smaller units should be denied the right
to engage in collective bargaining
back when I was doing this work I recall
getting phone calls from
groups that want to negotiate
and my statement to them was and at that
point most of the large units were
already
organized so smaller units were calling
and I would often have to say to them
before we can move forward you have to
be able to count to ten
on many occasions they said but there's
only eight of us
there's only six of us there's only nine
of us anything less than 10 can't be
certified
and I often had to just turn them away
saying this project is dead in the water
there's nowhere to go for you
so please join me in supporting our
dedicated public sector workers for
municipal workers to Firefighters police
School Employees County and state
employees by pressing the green button
in support of the ought to pass motion
and Mr Speaker I ask for a division vote
thank you
a vision has been requested members take
your seats
okay
foreign
this is a division vote chair recognized
representative seaworth for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that this bill would cut in half
the threshold required to form a
collective bargaining unit
and if I know that this would
disproportionately impact the smallest
communities here in New Hampshire would
I not then press the red button
to maintain the status quo in our
current law thank you
chair recognize representative Susie for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
believe that all public sector employees
should have the right to belong to a
bargain unit of their choice and if I
know that the current law requires the
minimum of 10 employees for a
certification vote to occur which makes
it difficult for employees of smaller
municipalities to organize and finally
Mr Speaker if I know that house bill 150
would lower the number of employees from
10 to 5 allowing these smaller groups of
employees to the ability to organize
then when I now support the ought to
pass motion by pressing the green button
thank you Mr Speaker the motion before
us is ought to pass on House Bill 150
they say division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose or press the red button while
these stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
while members president had an
opportunity to vote I also tend to stay
the vote
204 voting a 179 voting a committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on labor
industrial today the services to which
referred House Bill 561 enact
establishing a committee to examine
Workforce and school accommodations for
those with long-term covered in
mecfs sit at the same report the same
the following resolution resolved is in
expedient to legislate present Evangel
proud for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation not to build out of
classrooms in Joshua adjutant for the
minority of the committee
chair recognized representative Sullivan
for a motion
Mr chairman I make a motion to table
this bill
the motion before us is the table House
Bill
561. are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
the eyes have it and
House Bill 561 is laid on the table
joining the committee on legislative
Administration which was referred to
cacr-4
enact relating to compensation for
legislators providing that legislators
biannual salary compensation shall be
increased consider the same report the
same with the following resolution that
is in expedient to legislate
Senator Stephen Pearson from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and be an
unable to agree with the majority Report
with a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass
into space Stephanie parior for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative
sorry I'd like to make a motion to table
please motion to table
the motion to table cacr4
the division has been requested members
take their seats
foreign
okay
house will be in order
the Martian before us is the table cacr4
this is going to be a
division vote
are you ready
I got lost here for a second I'm sorry
this is going to be a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your opposed will press
the red button boarding stations are
open for 30 seconds
video
representative D Silvestro
of our members president on opportunity
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
153 voting a 229 voting a the table
emotion fails we're back to the majority
committee report of inexpedian to
legislate
chair recognizes
representative power
pay your I'm sorry pay your
yes
because
yeah the house will be in order the
member has a right to be heard
I rise in opposition of the itl on cacr4
during committee I like that this bill
was bipartisan in the presentation by my
colleague from Claremont
was logical and well done we do not
believe that our Founders intended to
keep the stipend of two hundred dollars
set in 1889 stagnant for 134 plus years
this bill is an update to a number that
was reasonable in 1889 but is no longer
reasonable in 2023 due to inflation
I think we can all agree that being a
state representative is indeed a job be
it part-time for some or full-time for
others depending on your committee the
role requires a significant time
commitment that takes us away from our
regular jobs time with family and other
responsibilities
this bill adjusts the two hundred dollar
stipend set in 1889 for a two-year term
to a more realistic value of five
thousand dollars for a two-year term
to help defray costs that we all
encounter be that meals missed work days
Child Care coverage or hotels booked
during bad weather or long evenings such
as this week
just as elected officials in our towns
and cities receive reasonable stipends
for their roles on the select board City
councils School boards Etc
it is appropriate to adjust the stipend
to a modern day value to reflect the
time commitment and expenses incurred
while doing the job of a legislator
Mr Speaker I request a division vote
thank you
Jay I recognize representative Stephen
Pearson
the house will be in order
thank you Mr speaker thank you
colleagues
this is pretty simple
since pretty much World War one we have
become a volunteer legislature so here's
your choice do we stay being a volunteer
legislature
or do we become kind of a half-paid
legislature with a per diem
that's simply what the choice is
we're over a hundred years now of being
a part-time volunteer legislature
we all volunteered to be here today
because we all decided to run for office
and that's a simple choice
the committee felt that we should
continue to be a volunteer legislature
so I ask you to support the itl motion
and keep the tradition of this body
alive thank you a division has been
requested
a roll call has been suggested that is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
I don't know they all stood up at once
I guess you could use turquoise he's
waving his hands
the motion before us is majority commit
a report of house will be in order
committee report of inexpensary to
legislation cacr-4 this is a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
Stapleton for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if I know that we've got many great
traditions in this house
but that one hundred dollars a year
salary is not one of them
and if I know that the 100 rate was set
way back in 1889
134 years ago
when the dollar was really worth
something
and it is woefully meager stipend right
now at today's value not covering the
many expenses
that are unreimbursed
either by the hundred dollars or by a
per diem or by mileage
and I'm thinking of
unreimbursed campaigns expenses
time off from work to come here to do
the people's business
and I know on both sides of the aisle
there are two ladies with Children Here
and would they be suited to have some
Child Care expense for child care
I could go on and on all day long with
this and you know it but I'm not going
to
and if I know
that this is not a race we're giving
ourselves but rather an effort just to
keep
just to recoup the many
uncompensated expenses we incur
in time and effort to do this work while
missing work
and if I know that we're not determined
representative this is a parliamentary
inquiry not a speech
and if I know that we're not determining
the charge the any change in part one
Article 15 of the Constitution but
rather bringing it up to date
and letting the voters do that we're not
voting ourselves a raise we're letting
the voters make a decision but
representative parliamentary not a
speech press the green button to let the
measure go to the people where if I
press the red button so that we could
make a motion to go to the people like
we should be doing in this body
and I uh thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize representative shahan
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that about two
dozen bills like this have been
unsuccessfully brought to our committee
in recent history
and if I know that without any urgent
reasons shown we should never just
arbitrarily take on a change to the
Constitution that has served us well for
hundreds of years
and finally Mr Speaker if I know that
many in our state take pride in having a
volunteer citizen legislature
would I now press the green button and
support the committee recommendation of
inexpedient to legislate thank you Mr
Speaker
the motion me for us is the majority
committee report of index meeting to
legislate on caci for this is a roll
call vote you're in favor you'll press
the green button of your opposed or
press the red button learning stations
are open for 30 seconds
foreign
ER
wall members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend a
state of the vote
239 voting yay 145 voting a the
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on Municipal
and County government to which was
deferred House Bill 423 act relative to
accessory dwelling unit uses Allowed by
right considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is in expedient to
legislation of John McDonnell for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass Senator David priest for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes Senator Speer
uh
send a spear waves off the chair
recognize representative priests
Mr speaker thank you and good afternoon
I Rise to speak against the motion to
itl HB 423
New Hampshire is experiencing a severe
housing crisis
and it's continuing to affect our
economic growth and stability
nimbyism and restrictive land use
regulations in communities
have made it difficult for developers to
keep up with the demand for housing in
New Hampshire
as a result more than 5 000 people
including 1200 families
are experiencing homelessness in New
Hampshire
people including some working full-time
are living in cars shelters tents and
other people's living room floors
the vacancy rate is less than 0.1
percent for market rate units
and rents are continuing to climb
an average wage earner has to earn over
thirty dollars an hour just to afford an
average two-bedroom apartment
applied economic research estimated that
New Hampshire's housing market needs at
least 20 000 new housing units to
satisfy the current market demand
HB 223 would increase the number of
accessory dwelling units
Allowed by right from one to two
change the attached unit definition and
increase the maximum square footage from
750 to 1000 square feet
this bill would also give towns the
right to require that one of those
dwelling units
be to meet the purpose of Workforce
housing
the housing crisis continues and this
bill if enacted will be one of the tools
to create more housing
by allowing more accessory dwelling
units on single-family Lots this bill
will help to build affordable housing
for people for all ages
including
I should say allowing homeowners to add
apartments for seniors like our parents
and grandparents
as well as young people like our
children who are coming back to college
with severe debt and want to establish a
new life in our communities
an accessory dwelling unit would have to
comply with the municipal zoning
ordinance requirements for single-family
dwelling units including setbacks and
off-street parking and they have to
prove that there is adequate public and
private Water and Sewer capacity to
serve the additional accessory dwelling
units
if New Hampshire wants a bright economic
future
and to address the increasing homeless
problem plaguing our cities and towns we
must address the affordable housing
crisis
I urge my colleagues to press the red
button and oppose itla HB 423 so that an
alternative motion can be made
and Mr chairman I asked for a division
vote
I'm sorry
Mr Speaker I'm sorry I asked for a
division vote
do you recognize representative turcotte
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
as you're well aware this is now a uh
the third in a series of bills that
attempts to place State mandates by
Central planners in this case this body
upon all the municipalities in our state
the bill would require any property that
currently allows a single accessory
dwelling unit
to now allow two and it also increases
the size of those units just like we
discussed on these other two bills I'm
not going to go through the long Litany
of items as to why we don't need to do
it but towns and cities already have the
ability to accomplish what this bill
tries to do and they can do that through
their zoning regulations
the new New Hampshire municipality
Association has also confirmed that they
are opposed to this bill specifically
not unlike the other ones where anytime
they try to put a universal mandate down
onto a municipality they have been
opposed and they are opposed to this one
also
finally the bill is laced once again
legislation that's being forced upon the
municipalities and mandated without
regard to any fiscal or social impacts
so once again for the third time I ask
that you find this find this Bill itl
thank you Mr Speaker
I recognize representative of Ocala for
a motion
thank you Mr Speaker I make a motion to
table
HP 432
it is a proper motion the motion before
us is the table House Bill 423
and he requests a division vote yes
thank you
members take your seats this will be a
division vote
thank you
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 423 this is a division vote chair
recognized representative Keller for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know I sit on
the special committee on housing and
we're tasked to looking at solutions to
this housing crisis and Mr Speaker if I
know that there's no Silver Bullet toast
solution
um but there are maybe some parts of
some Merit to parts of this bill then
would I press the green button to lay
this bill on the table so that's a
special committee can look into this
further thank you
do you recognize representative land
turquot for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
if I know this body has already heard
two similar bills and if I also know
neither of those bills were worthy of
tabling and were instead found itl by
wide bipartisan margins
would I now press the red button to
avoid tabling this bill and allowed this
bill to join its sister bills with the
same disposition of itl thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is to lay
House Bill 423 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press a green button if you're opposal
press a red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
okay
representative Murad
Walmart was present an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
203 voting yay 178 voting a hb4 or 23 is
laid on the table
Committee on Public Works and highways
to which was referred House Bill 480
enact relative to the intersection
between route 302 and East Conway Road
Conway having considered the same report
the same with the falling resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate president David milts for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
Committee on Public Works to which was
referred House Bill 511 FN act relative
to acquiring the Department of
Transportation to do road maintenance
and repairs according to its complete
streets program considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpeding to
legislation of John claudier for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
[Music]
your eyes have it in the committee
report is adopted
the committee on resources Recreation
development tuition was referred House
Bill 205 relative to testing Wells
chair recognized representative renzullo
thank you Mr Speaker I moved to uh table
house bill 205.
Jennifer Renewables renzuela moves the
table House Bill 205
are you ready for the question I wish to
speak on the oh well no I will go ahead
I'm sorry are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
opposing a the eyes have it in House
Bill 205 is laid on the table
community members
committee on science at College NH also
be in order
committee on science technology and 92
which was referred House Bill 139
relative definition of Municipal host
for purposes of limited electrical
energy producers producers comes without
recommendation moves
ought to pass the chair recognize
representative Summers
what region memorized
to make a motion Mr Speaker stage of
motion I moved to table house bill 139.
the motion is in order the motion before
us is a table House Bill 139 and
division has been requested members take
your seats
not no not yet
the motion before us is the table house
bill 139.
this is a division vote chair recognized
representative vote voice
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that in committee
this bill was reconsidered because there
was an appetite to try to find a
bipartisan compromise
if I also know that that by attempt at
bipartisan compromise failed
indicating that this bill needs
additional work
and finally
if I know that
the bill
as it's currently written is confusing
in many ways
when I press the green button to table
this Bill thank you Mr Speaker
is representative McGee
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill has come up for a second time in
our committee because there is a need
between committees to be able to partner
on solar projects
and that the need has come up to our
committee for consideration and for
solution multiple times and it is a very
small and simple change that says that a
municipal host does not have to just be
in one municipality but bordering towns
can put in on projects together in order
to lower their costs and would I now
allow the debate to go forward so you
can hear the point thanks
the motion before us is the table House
Bill 139 this is a division vote if
you're in favor we'll press a green
button to be opposer press a red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
representative Morgan
representative bull
representative Petrie
you can't push it
foreign
opportunity to vote house will tend to
stay the vote
179 148 197 voting aided tabling motion
fails we're back to the odd motion about
to pass
care recognized representative Summers
that the house will be in order the
member has a right to be heard
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker I rise today in opposition HB
our electrical grid is a marvelous
machine that looked that took decades to
build and perfect
tampering with or adjusting that machine
requires careful deliberation and
planning
renewable generation of electricity has
many pluses
but its intermittency can destabilize
the grid
it needs to be expanded in small
carefully planned increments to avoid
causing disruptions in Supply and spike
in prices
in 2021 New Hampshire expanded its net
metering program to include counties and
municipalities
this modest expansion was good for
taxpayers even though it did shift some
costs to ratepayers
it demonstrated how growing Renewables
on the grid can be done at a careful and
deliberate pace
for example
in Rockingham County in which I serve
the new County complex being built over
the next two years will feature a 4.99
megawatt solar farm that will power the
entire complex including the nursing
home the jail and the new home of the
administrative offices of the County
Attorney register of deeds and other
departments
this project will use the municipal host
group net metering program to provide
lower costs for County taxpayers
hb139 however
takes a haphazard approach to expanding
Renewables by removing one of the
safeguards put in place to manage net
metering growth allowing systems to
cross Municipal boundaries will likely
lead to a sharp uptick in large systems
that serve towns that located near one
another
these large systems will be built by
private companies whose motive will be
to Garner profits and more government
subsidies
a more careful and deliberate expansion
could permit adjoining towns to create
Municipal and net metering groups
groups based on neighboring towns would
likely be smaller and provide for modest
and manageable net metering expansion
since hb139 does not offer this approach
it does not offer a carefully planned
increment to this program
in addition the Public Utilities
Commission is currently deliberating
changes to the net metering program
that's why the department of energy
opposes this bill as well
therefore I urge you to vote no on the
ought to pass motion so that a better
motion can be made
Mr Speaker
remember yield to questions
yes
remember yields you may inquire
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
representative taking my question would
you also agree that this bill greatly
expands the scope of the net metering
the net metering Municipal host because
it brings in things like housing
authorities peas Development Authority
and any other organization that's funded
by a municipality for whatever reasons
this is a huge expansion to this program
do you agree
that's correct representative I agree
with you
chair recognizer representative
Christian
thank you Mr Speaker so this is a very
simple bill that extends the many
benefits of Municipal net metering but
my colleague very kindly described for
us the most important thing that it does
it just removes the language requiring
the users of the energy to be all in one
municipality so there are many towns in
New Hampshire that have sites that might
like to
um
sorry that might have enough space
available for a large facility but might
not have enough off takers to take all
the power that they would generate maybe
their neighbor
um has some use for the power but not
space to create a facility so this bill
would simply allow them to enter an
agreement with a neighboring town or
city that doesn't have that space But
would like to reap the benefits of
renewable generation this just allows
more flexibility for our cities and
towns to develop local energy in a way
that works best for them saves where you
pay our money saves Municipal money and
costs nothing to the state
and yes the other aspect of this bill is
that it adds housing authorities the
peace development and other quasi-public
entities again to make a very measured
small expansion of this very successful
and popular program to a few more
governmental units I hope you will
support this very reasonable modest
expansion of Municipal net metering
thank you
oh and I request a division vote thank
you
a roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
foreign
thank you
the motion before us is auto pass and
House Bill 139 this is a roll call vote
which Eric and Ice representative wolves
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that this bill
removes the guard rails created by this
body that prevent runaway growth in the
municipal host group net metering
program
if I also know that removing this
protection will derail the deliberate
and well-planned Adoption of renewable
energy
too much of which can destabilize the
grid and increase costs
finally if I know that haphazard
policies like hb-139 can lead to
unintended consequences like the current
interconnection backlog in Massachusetts
that will take years and tens of
millions of dollars to clear
when I now press the red button to reply
to protect the reliability of our grid
and keep electricity prices as low as
possible thank you Mr Speaker chair
recognize representative Corman for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that Municipal net
metering Municipal net metering
benefits all the taxpayers of a
municipality by lowering Municipal
energy costs
and if I know that this bill makes it
possible to expand Municipal net
metering then Mr Speaker would I press
the green button and vote to support
expanded Municipal net metering and
benefit taxpayers
the motion before us ought to pass on
House Bill 139 it's a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press a green
button of your pulse or press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
thank you
me
fall members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
188 40 day 186 voting May
committee report is adopted Mr Speaker
member rise having voted on the
prevailing side I would like to move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote no and a division please
the motion before us is reconsideration
on House Bill 139 division has been
requested
yes
the motion before us is a
reconsideration on House Bill 139 this
is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press a green
button if you're a poster press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
representative Terry
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
185 48 192 149 reconsideration fails
majority of the committee on science
technology and energy to which those
referred House Bill 142 and act relative
to the operation of the Burgess power
plant considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment the
recommendation of Bill ought to pass
with Amendment representative Michael
voce for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is in
expedient to legislate representative
Michael Harrington for the minority of
the committee
the amendment is
0939h printed in House Records 16 page
62. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
Dr bosnay the eyes have it and the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with Amendment
the chair recognized representative
Harrington
thank you Mr Speaker just a little
background on this in case those people
don't realize it everyone gets an
electric bill most people get it from
eversource if you get one there's a
little thing you'll see they're called
Stranded cost the overwhelming majority
stranded costs the money that you're
subsidizing the burgers by biomass plant
with they pursued and signed a contract
some years ago with eversource they
wanted it they couldn't have built their
plant without it and in there there was
a strike price of eighty dollars a
megawatt hour by that I mean they get
paid eighty dollars a megawatt hour from
eversource which means from the rate
payers eversource just passes the cost
through 100 it costs them nothing
and if the actual market price of
electricity during any given hour is
above that then Burgess gets a credit if
it's below that they get a charge well
over the last approximately 10 years
they've racked up a lot of charges about
150 million dollars worth of charges
to put that in perspective I think
everyone realizes last January we had
very very high uh Market rates what
retail as well as
market-based wholesale rates if they ran
in January for one day if they ran 24
hours on an average January day they
would have racked up about 30 thousand
dollars in charges because the market
rate in January was averaged about 55 a
megawatt hour even though it was one of
the highest we've ever had it was 25
below the rate that was negotiated by
Burgess biomass so what it comes down to
is they've signed a contract they don't
want to live up to
they never have and never will be able
to make the terms of the contract so
it's time to stop the bleeding they've
we brought this up a year and a half ago
and asked them to come forward with the
plan be ready to come back with how are
you going to deal with this because the
electric prices even though they've gone
up substantially have not gone up
anywhere enough to cover the cost of
that eighty dollars a megawatt hour they
came back in the hearings we had
recently and had nothing to say they had
no plan no option just one
representative who was from that area in
the Berlin area said we'll be back next
year requesting more money and that's
the only way they're going to stay
afloat
they the bill does nothing to address
the real cause that 80 is still there it
simply says well we're going to knock
off 50 million dollars of the 150 that
the rate pays have already shelled out
and not require them to pay that back it
doesn't do anything to prevent the
inevitable bankruptcy of this company if
indeed they go they keep going the only
possibility is they could sell the plant
it's happened to other plants the
Londonderry gas-fired plant which is
more than 10 times bigger than this
plant uh went bankrupt and they were
sold for cents on the dollar it's up
running now and making a profit I don't
can't sit here and stand in front of you
and say that that could happen for
Burgess but it might be able to happen
but I can guarantee you if they continue
to run all they're going to do is rack
up more money what the bill says is give
them 50 million dollars of rate payer
money that they get to keep but then
they're going to have to start paying it
back in accordance with the contract
they can't do it so we'll will be back
here a year from now and they'll be
begging for more money because they have
no other option they have no there's no
way of doing it they can try
renegotiating the contract but I don't
think that's going to work there's no
nothing forces ever source to do it
remember this was a voluntary contract
by two parties no one made either side
sign it so what would happen if we knock
them back to 100 million dollars it's
just going to delay the inevitable a
little bit longer because they'll be
racking up that build and once it goes
over 100 million they have to start
paying the money back to the to the rate
payers and they simply can't do it so
let's stop the bleeding let's put this
to an end if they have to go bankrupt if
they have to sell the plant whatever the
sooner the better because the longer
that plant operates the more they're
going to owe the rate payers is they
can't pay back so if you like paying
that cost in the stranded cost in your
electric bill and by all means vote in
favor of this bill but if you say 150
million dollars is enough and it's time
to stop the bleeding please push the red
button thank you
jerich and Ice representative voice
speaker
when I was growing up
my mother and father taught me that it's
okay to make mistakes
but if you do make a mistake you should
admit it
apologize for it if necessary fix it if
you can
and learn from it
in 2018
this legislature and our governor
made a mistake
they passed Senate Bill 577
which granted a suspension of the terms
of a contract negotiated between two
private companies
for a period of three years
last year
Senate Bill 271 which we all approved
extended
that suspension by another year
in November of this year that suspension
expires
what happens then according to the terms
of the contract that the two parties
signed and I'm talking about
eversource the utility and Burgess power
the wood burning generating plant and
Berlin
what happens at the end of the
suspension period is that Berlin has to
pay back
all the money that is accumulated during
that four-year suspension period they've
said they they can't do that
and an independent audit by the
department of energy which was part of
Senate Bill 271 last year confirmed that
they don't have the financial resources
to pay this money back
so it's clear now and I realize that
hindsight is 2020 but it's clear now
that it was a mistake for the
legislature to get involved in this
process in the first place
that four-year suspension allowed 50
million dollars to accumulate
that now suddenly
needs to be paid back according to the
Public Utilities Commission and the
terms of the contract
well Burgess says he can't pay it back
the purpose of House Bill 122 is amended
by the committee
is to admit that we made a mistake
we shouldn't have created that four-year
suspension period which allowed 50
million dollars in over-market charges
to accumulate
and put the commit to put the company
Berlin Burgess biopower in Jeopardy
because it has to pay it back
so this bill is amended by the committee
forgives that over-market accumulation
of over-market charges which amounts to
roughly 48 to 50 million dollars it's
already been recovered from ratepayers
so it's not like it's a new
obligation that we'll have to discharge
it simply forgives
the company Burgess biopower from their
obligation under the terms of their
contract to pay it back
it essentially resets the terms of the
PPA that they signed
to 2018 before this suspension went into
effect
now Burgess signed that contract
willingly as did eversource
and we should allow them
both parties here
to live by the terms of this contract it
is illegally binding contract
we must resist
the Temptation I think to rescue every
entity that makes a mistake
whether that's a Silicon Valley Bank
or a New Hampshire supplier of
electricity
if we pass this bill and forgive this 48
to 50 million dollar
quote unquote debt of over-market
charges
that accumulated only because this
legislature intervened
we will allow the parties to resume the
performance of their contract
however that works out
will be between them and it's not
something that we should get involved
with
but I think
that by passing this legislation we give
them a chance we throw them a Lifeline
that says okay
now you've got to live by the terms of
your contract if it's not going to work
then maybe you need to re renegotiate
that contract
by passing this bill we will extend a
lifeline
to the loggers and the truckers in the
North country
to the taxpayers of the city of Berlin
to everybody who cares about the quality
of New Hampshire forests
I urge you to press the green button and
say yes
to this important legislation thank you
Mr Speaker
the senator has requested a roll call
and is sufficiently seconded this will
be a roll call vote
the motion before us was ought to pass
as amended on House Bill 142
house will be in order
this is a roll call vote
gear recognized representative
Harrington for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if you
know like I know that you can't throw a
Lifeline to someone who's already
drowned and if you know that this
Burgess biomass plant is only going to
rack up more debt if we allow this bill
to pass and if you know like I know that
it's time to stop the bleeding and it's
time to stop them from collecting more
rate payer money and rate payer
subsidies by pushing the green the red
button thank you
Geo recognize representative votes for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker if I know that while hb142
May Kick the Can down the road at least
it keeps it out of the ditch
and if I also know that government
cannot fix every problem especially not
when it tips the scale between two
parties in one party's favor
finally if I know that this bill throws
a lifeline to North Country loggers and
truckers and to the citizens and
taxpayers of Greater Berlin
what I now press the green button to
reset the clock to 2018 and give the
companies involved the incentive
incentive to work out a better plan
thank you Mr Speaker the motion before
us is the majority committee report of
autopaths has amended on House Bill 142.
this is a roll call vote here in favor
you'll press the green button of your
approach or press a red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
[Music]
fall members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
100 269 voting yay 109 voting a
committee report is adopted
before we get to the next bill
we have some special guests up in the
gallery
it's the Mongolian prosecutors with the
friends forever International
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
[Applause]
the house will be in order
the majority of committee on ways and
means to which was deferred House Bill
486 FN act relative to vehicle
registrations to reciprocal toll
collection enforcement agreements having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative Cecilia's for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass so Jordan early for the minority of
the committee
chair recognize representative
State your motion
I moved to table this bill
president what was the table House Bill
486 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye those opposed
nay
your eyes have it and House Bill 486 is
laid on the table
majority of the committee on ways and
means to which was referred House Bill
510 FN
enact relative to removing the exemption
from premium cigars from the tobacco tax
having considered the same report the
same with the falling resolution resolve
that is inexpecting to Legacy Senator
David roachford for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same be an unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Richard ainsman
minority of the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
or supposedly the eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted
um
majority of the committee on ways and
means to which was referred
House Bill 607 FN enact relative to the
regulation of games of chance considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment
then Fred you set for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same be an unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
Fallen resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate
committee amendment is one zero two four
h printed in house record 16 pages
93-96. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
there's a postnay the ice have it and
the committee members have adopted
the bills open bills on second reading
and open to further Amendment the chair
recognizes
representative Doucette who bring forth
floor Amendment
1103 H it's in your seat pockets
thank you Mr Speaker
my colleague from Jaffrey and I offer
this amendment 1103
to the end of the line Bill 607 what
this does in effect is it clarifies
a
component in in the legislation that
speaks to a specific game the historic
horse racing that we passed last
biennium in in that legislation we put a
drop dead date or a a lock on who can
apply for those licenses to the present
15 rooms that we have in state in that
legislation that allows for a Sunset
date of July of 24. as we can all
appreciate the supply line challenges
some of the challenges with licensing
applications at present seven
of the 15 rooms are up and running to a
certain percentage with this game this
amendment
changes what was proposed in the
legislation from a full and complete
moratorium of any more expansion of this
particular game and sets a date of July
of 2029 which allows the Lottery
Commission time to uh
review and best address any issues that
may affect both the state and the
Charities interests
thank you Mr Speaker
the motion under the Ames 4 Amendment
1103h are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the names for
amendment is adopted the bill is now on
auto pass with Amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
opal's name
the eyes have it and the committee
amendment is adopted committee report is
adopted
when I want bills removed from consent
committee on children and family law to
which was referred H.R 14 and that
enact a resolution to urge investigation
of due process and family court cases
having considered this the same report
the same with the following Amendment a
recommendation to fill out a password
Amendment senator Pat long for the
committee
chair recognizes representative Pearson
to make a motion sir say commotion I put
this bill on the table
Senator Pearson moves at H.R 14 be laid
on the table are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
protocols nay the eyes the eyes have it
and H.R 14 is laid on the table
committee on Congress and consumer
affairs to which was referred House Bill
648 FN in act relative to establishing a
State Bank of New Hampshire having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpeding to legislate
Representative Keith Airman for the
committee
chair recognized representative Gerhart
thank you speaker
the house will be in order the member
has a right to be heard
all right I know it's late so just be
real quick at this North Dakota has had
its own public Bank since 1919. this
bank takes tax revenue from the state
and then reinvests it in the state
keeping the money local
system
when you build a bridge or public other
public infrastructure half the cost of
that project goes to interest payments
to the mega Corporation Banks and I just
don't see any reason we need to do that
and I'd like to keep this in our toolkit
so that the banks are collapsing right
now we kind of know what's going on and
we can kind of lie and say oh they're
all safe they're not and there's
actually no Reserve requirement right
now for banks for the banks so
there's no need for them to keep any
money in their vault they just keep on
asking the feds for more and more and as
we know the printing presses keep going
verb so
I don't want to take a whole bunch of
time just going to say last thing is
this public Bank does not compete with
local banks so North Dakota is 12 banks
for every 100 000 people per capita and
the U.S average is two
so if we're really trying to
help the people of New Hampshire and
keep our costs down
and not just burn money on these banks
are going to take our tax dollars and
put them out of state then I would
urge you guys to pass this Bill thank
you
chair recognize representative Horgan
thank you very much
um I uh this bill has been a perennial
it's been kicking around for a number of
years with a wide variety of sponsors
and I've sponsored it I've co-sponsored
it a few times I thank the member from
Northfield for stepping forward it uh
seems more timely than they did last
year with the growing instability in the
banking industry especially the failure
of the high-flying Silicon Valley Bank
and he pretty much
summed everything up all I really need
to add is that it's it's a fairly well I
mean it's kind of a long Bill if you
want to if you're anywhere trying to
absorb it all on your phones while
you're sitting here
but it's uh short for the complication
of the topic if passed as is all hb648
does it establishes a board of directors
and an accompanying advisory commission
along with authorizing uh jail card The
Joint legislative committee on
administrative rules to begin the rule
making process and the rules will
presumably be
quite voluminous
and then the state treasurer and the
bank commissioner and the Attorney
General will be asked to write a startup
plan and that would include
recommendations there'd be a lot of
future legislation needed to flesh out
to start a plan so that's going to take
several years so I if if you need to
take my advice and overturn the itl if
we actually passed it we'd just be
starting a uh process that's going to
take a whole bunch of several years and
what is the Bank of North Dakota it's
Unique but it has worked well in North
Dakota I think we need something similar
here so uh I urge you to overturn the
itl some more appropriate motion can be
introduced so thanks
do you recognize representative by the
way I'm feeling much better thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker
I'm so glad I got a chance to speak in
these last two days here
I was asked to table this bill and I
said no I think it's important that the
people who who support the bill should
have a chance to speak and let you know
what they think and how they want this
Bill yes it is true Commerce has seen
this bill multiple times over the years
and yes it is true the North Dakota did
back in
1919 did create a bank it was necessary
for North Dakota at the time because the
farmers were unable to get loans from
the community from the banks that were
in that time back then Banks didn't have
Financial requirements they were pretty
kind of loosey-goosey and evidently they
weren't loan into farmers and so the
state decided to step in in the meantime
here in New Hampshire all the different
benefits that that North Dakota Bank
does provide to all those different the
farmers but also to the citizens are
actually right now being provided by
nifa for student loans the business
Finance Authority does business findings
so we have all the same things that that
bank does but we just operate it a
little differently and as a matter of
fact we do it like the other 48 states
do it so I would urge you to vote with
the committee to make this bill and
expedient to literature site thank you
[Music]
oh
the most the motion before us is the
inexpedient legislative committee report
on HBO HB 648 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposing a
you guys have it committee report is
adopted
committee on Health and Human Services
now the Affairs to which those referred
House Bill 277 and act relative to
patients rights to sterilization
treatment having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that as in expedient
to legislators in a rare lay on for the
committee chair recognizer
representative line to make a motion
I moved
that week General moves the table House
Bill 277. she's asked for a division
this will be a division vote members
take his seats
foreign
House Bill 277 on the table
this is going to be a division vote the
chair recognizes the representative Leon
for a parliamentary inquiry
believe that
that may face few obstacles to
vasectomies and yet women are sometimes
denied medical care which results in
sterilization because the doctor thinks
that she might want to have children in
the future and they think that that
desire is actually more important than
the medical condition
and if I know that house bill 277
attempted to right this wrong but we
just couldn't get there in time and if I
recognize the broad support to fix this
problem would I then press the green
button to table this Bill thank you
motion before us is the table House Bill
277 this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button if you're
opposed press the right button quoting
stations are open for 30 seconds
foreign
representative papaichi Mueller
of all members president an opportunity
to vote house was 10th of the state of
the vote
200 367 voted yay
eight voting a house bill 277 is laid on
the table
how the house will be in order that was
the last bill we're almost done so
everybody please stay in your seats for
a couple of minutes
the chair recognize the member from
Auburn represent Osborne for third
reading motion
thank you Mr Speaker resolved that the
hiring from the early session that the
business of the late session be in order
at the present time at the reading of
bills be by title only and resolutions
by caption only and that all bills
ordered a third reading be read a third
time by this resolution and that all
titles of bills be the same as adopted
and that they be passed at the present
time and when the house adjourns today
at B to meet at the call of the chair
questions on the third reading motion
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
you guys have it
I'll move on to announcements
the chair recognized to representative
Wilder
we have a few unanimous consents we
still have a couple more things to do so
with everybody please just stay seated
for a couple of minutes
hello
some of you asked me how do I learn more
about the budget
show Monday and Tuesday starting at 10
o'clock in rooms 210 211 over in the LLB
we're going to be having since we
divvied it up into three divisions each
division is going to have to brief the
other two on what they've done so
anybody else that wants to hear about
the budget can come and listen for those
hours I guess it will also be telecast I
will also be having another presentation
in April just before we vote on the
budget but this one is be lengthy and
detailed so you're all welcome to come
there'll be space for you in 2 10 to 11
Monday Tuesday starting at 10 o'clock
both days thank you
chair recognize the clerk for
announcement
chair recognizes representative Schmidt
for an announcement
if you're from this thank you Mr Speaker
if you're from the Stratford County
delegation pay attention if you're not
you don't have to Stratford County
delegation will be meeting next
Wednesday at seven o'clock to vote on
the county budget please
be in attendance thank you
now that now the chair recognizes the
clerk thank you Mr Speaker just a
reminder to members please remove your
items from your seat Pockets uh today we
do have other things happening in here
next week so please go ahead and take
everything home thank you
before we get to Indianapolis consent
I think you ought to all give yourselves
a highly Applause for getting done this
quick
[Applause]
and this
and this successful without having to go
past six o'clock on either day
chair recognize representative Damon for
unanimous consent
okay
colleagues
good afternoon the house will be in
order
thank you Mr Speaker good afternoon
colleagues thank you for tolerating
Indiana's consent I know it's been a
long day
I stand before you for recognition of
March National Women's history month and
I stand with my education committee
colleagues of both parties and others
who value the role of women in state
government
and if I asked all of the women here to
come down it would be about a third of
the house and less people to be speaking
to
and if I asked all the men who value
women in government I think we'd all be
on this side of the podium at least I
hope so
so as I briefly acknowledge some
significant women in New Hampshire
history I ask you to also reflect on the
women who have contributed to your
opportunities and successes
I am the granddaughter of a suffragette
Mabel Merit
1895-2000. yes she touched three
centuries and lived to be 105. Graham
was 25 when women in the U.S achieved
the right to vote
she understood the privilege and value
of voting never missed an election and I
carry her with me every day
in my first term as a New Hampshire
state representative I feel enormous
responsibility as one woman with a small
role to play in democracy
I entered these walls with reverence for
our history and respect for our
democracy
the New Hampshire women's Foundation a
Statewide nonpartisan non-profit reports
that in the 2022 elections
the other side of the wall
reached gender parity for the first for
the second time with 12 of the 24
members being women we had the first
state legislative body thank you
with more women than men in 2008
currently the New Hampshire house has 37
women 37 percent women of which 100 are
Democrats and 48 are Republicans
notable New Hampshire women include and
the list could go on forever I assure
you I will not
Harriet Wilson of Milford the first
African-American of any gender to
publish a novel in North America
Harriet patient's Dame the first woman
to have her portrait hung at our state
house she was a prominent nurse in the
American Civil War Christ captured
Marilla Ricker was the first female
lawyer in New Hampshire the first woman
to run for governor a suffragist and a
philanthropist she paved the way for
women to be accepted into the New
Hampshire bar and made significant
lasting contributions to women's rights
when Ms Ricker announced her campaign
for governor in 1910 ten years before
she acquired the right to vote
she said I'm running for governor in
order to get people in the habit of
thinking of women as governors
people have to about to think about a
thing for several centuries before they
got acclimated to the idea
fortunately it did not take centuries
in 1920 the 19th Amendment to the U.S
Constitution confirmed women's right to
vote New Hampshire elected two women to
the state house that year on write-in
campaigns Jesse doe and Dr Mary Louise
Farnam
44 years later Dudley Dudley became the
first woman on the executive Council her
portrait is here at the state house as
well
New Hampshire was the first state in the
U.S to have an all-woman Congressional
Delegation as you all know probably we
were the first state to elect the same
woman to be both governor and state
senator which we have now done twice and
I don't think any other state has done
it once yet
all of this is not only good for women
it is good for our country
women's life experience are different
than men's not better not worse but
different
having women's perspectives and voices
at the table in positions of power to
make collaborative decisions is
necessary to everyone's well-being
especially since we have created such a
large table this week
role models in mentoring are incredibly
important to young people
seeing folks that you can relate to
people who look like you seeing women in
leadership roles helps young people
Envision themselves serving in similar
positions
of the 213 portraits at our state house
nine are women
I want to begin to work to change that
and I invite you to collaborate with me
I look forward to the time when women's
history is simply recognized as
inclusive to history when we have equal
representation at all levels of
government I thank you for your time and
I hope you all have a wonderful weekend
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I wish the remarks be printed
in the permanent Journal
well our objection
is representative McGee
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you all
for your Indulgence uh I just I'm up
here to talk to you about a volunteer
that many of you are familiar with if
you've been in the house for a while his
name is Jim Belanger and he is uh the
honorable Jim Belanger of Hollis whom I
served with in my first term and I have
been friends with for many years and I
will see him tonight on the zoning board
his family is having an event for him
this Sunday and he wanted me to make
sure that his friends in the house were
aware
that they are having a party for his
many years of volunteer service at the
Lawrence Barn in Hollis on Sunday the
26th from two to four and I told his
daughter that I would make that mention
here to make sure as many people as
cared for him and know him and respect
him
he used to be the chair of Municipal
County and government for several years
so if any of you can stop by I'm sure he
would love to see you thank you
chair recognizes representative Canon
foreign
thank you Mr Speaker
thank you all sticking around
March 31st is the international
transgender day of visibility it was
founded in 2009 to honor the
achievements and contributions of a
large community of very diverse
individuals
the international transgender day of
visibility is a time to celebrate the
lives and achievements of transgender
individuals around the world and to
recognize The Bravery it takes to live
openly and authentically
it is also a time to raise awareness of
the discrimination and violence that all
transgender Community still faces
which makes it difficult and even unsafe
or fatal for many transgender
individuals to be visible
the transgender Community has suffered
depression disproportionately in many
ways including discrimination and
employment in the workplace
discrimination educational institutions
and violence at the hands of others
gender individuals of color individuals
with limited resources immigrants
individuals living with disabilities
Justice involved individuals and
transgender youth experienced unwanted
unwarranted violence
more than 700 anti-transgender bills
have been submitted to legislatures
across the U.S during the years 2021 22
and 23.
yet the transgender Community has made
it clear that transgender individuals
will not be erased and deserve to be
accorded all the rights and
opportunities made available to all
before the creation of the United States
indigenous two-spirit
transgender individuals existed across
North America in many Native American
communities
with specific terms in their own
languages for these individuals and the
social and spiritual roles they
fulfilled in their communities
and while many Traditions were lost or
actively suppressed by the efforts of
missionaries government agents boarding
schools and settlers these Traditions
have experienced a Revival in recent
decades
transgender individuals continue to tell
their stories
and push for full Equity under the law
across our country
the Civil Rights struggle has been
strengthened and inspired by the
leadership of the transgender Community
transgender individuals in the United
States have made significant strides in
elected office and political
representation
at least 29 states have at least one
transgender elected official at the
state or Municipal level
there are no less than 18 transgender
transgender gender non-conforming or
non-binary elected officials serving in
our state legislatures
and even in our own legislature
our own James Rosner who's the first
openly transgender male in the country
is is one of our legislators Alessandra
Murray
and myself
also are here to represent the community
transgender individuals have created
culture and history as artists musicians
organizers and leaders
for many of us the international
transgender day of visibility it's a
time to celebrate the transgender
Community around the world
is a day when we recognize The Bravery
of the transgender Community as it
fights for equality and dignity and
respect
thank you
[Applause]
what reason to memorize
I would request the marks be printed in
the permanent journal without objection
General Wiseman moves at the house stand
in recess for the purpose of the
introduction of bills and Road build
amendments and roll build reports vacate
motions and receive new messages are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye those opposed the eyes
have it the motion is adopted the house
is in recess to the call of the chair